[Music]
n
a
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
I know it's
wrong but I don't
[Music]
care the fire is
strong but I don't care
all I ever want to be is eyes where eyes
this where lips skin please skin s
please
s eyes where eyes lips for lips skiny
skin s
your feel it down now now now think
about it later feel it down now now now
think about it later feel it now now now
now think about it later feel it now now
now now think about it
[Music]
later the damage is
done but I don't
care
[Music]
you're worth the
cost I don't
care what I ever want to be is eyes for
eyes lips for lips skin for skin sin for
sin Eyes For Eyes lies for your lips M
skin for your skin s for your
feel it
down think about it way there feel it
down now think about it later feel it
now now now now think about it later
feel it down down down now think about
it
[Music]
later what I ever want to be is eyes for
your eyes lips for your lips skin for
your skin s
[Music]
your as the world entered an unpr
precedented crisis Magnus Carlson and
chess 24 acted quickly to create the
first online chess tour of his kind
working 24/7 we brought together the
best players in the world for the
largest online prize fund ever broadcast
live in 10 languages the tour innovated
and filled the void created by the lack
of in-person play reaching more people
worldwide than any chess event live or
online ever there was fun and
laughter
okay it's time for Russian hackers to
attack uh internet in
Norway Last Hope come
on there was tension and controversy not
just make
moves yeah then give up the
phone this is hopeless Anish is fast
these
days interesting that
resigned
okay okay so we will have a fantastic
match tomorrow I'm
sure Yan is angry as hell
now but an also C his rhythm so let's
see it will be really fantastic there
were instructive learning moments now we
have discovered uh E6 was a very strong
move for neomia she opens up the
diagonal of the queen and at the same
time shot out the D5 Bishop from the
defense black has to play Rook E7 to
protect the pawn in the seventh ring but
now the queen comes from the F5 Queen F2
threatening Rook F7 and its curtains so
the position is collapsing right now
here black has to resign and there was
lots of great
chairs oh wow wow it's really uh an
incredible game like showing how a
complet lost position can gradually turn
into winning position if you just trade
all the right pieces it's really this
game is really a master pass on on the
trades what you should be trading and
what not and when I said that trading
the queens and the Bishops uh is good
for black I never imagined it would ever
happen because it's just it was so far
away from that wow and it's resignation
from ding four unique online events and
a grand final made up the Magnus Carlson
chess tour and the world took
notice the Magnus Carlson chess tour has
been the most watched online chess event
in history already it has become the
world's most prestigious series of
online tournaments as the first season
approaches its conclusion we want your
help to do something even bigger our
partner for the tour final is Kea the
nonprofit with a mission to expand
Financial access to help undeserved
communities Kea does incredible work
providing microloans to help people
around the world create opportunity for
themselves and their communities when
the pandemic started Kaa set up a global
covid-19 resp response fund to help
small businesses get back on their feet
their target to raise $50 million to
support thousands of people around the
world chess 24 wants to help make that
happen during the tour's final we will
be donating 50% of all proceeds from new
premium memberships to Kaa Go premium
and you will not just be supporting us
and getting the best chess entertainment
out there you will be supporting people
in times of need through Kea and if you
are premium already you can buy
sponsored premium memberships for
schools in cities and countries of your
choice in our shop Let's show how chess
can play its part
[Music]
together
a
[Music]
for
oh my gosh what a gorgeous Square to my
mind this queen on E5 is like a
goddess it's perfect it as you as you're
showing it's a it's a absolute pin on
The Rook there's a pin on the
queen uh talk about you know dark Square
domination against the bishop on B1
which is a light square piece this
is this is a dream
[Music]
move
hello and a big welcome to all of you
joining us for the Magnus Carlson chest
of benefiting Kaa final this is the last
leg of the tour it started with the
Magnus gson Invitational we moved on to
the lindera Sai rapid challenge then we
had the chessable Masters and finally
the legends of Chess before the four top
performers battle it out for
$300,000 in the Magnus Carlson chest
store final Magnus booked his spot into
the finals by winning the Invitational
Daniel dubov got in by sensationally
winning the Linder as Abby uh and
because Magnus also won the chess as
well as the legends of Chess it was the
highest cumulative scorers of the entire
tour which was Hikaru Nakamura and ding
Len who got in ironically it was because
Magnus won the legends of Chess that
Ding booked his spot into the finals and
going going into day two today Magnus
Carlson is playing catchup with ding
luren because what a blockbuster start
we had yesterday take a look at our
brackets it's Magnus Carlson up against
uh ding Len and Daniel Duba with Hikaru
Nakamura ding Len took down the world
champion and left no doubt that world
number three is indeed back in action
and back in form what an impressive play
that was the commentators uh Grand
Master yasa San Grandmaster Peter Leo
Hikaru joined us were all praised for
the way ding played especially the
Armageddon really impressed us with that
and Daniel dubo of Hikaru Nakamura was
just an epic struggle trading blows
starting with the Daniel winning the
first game in a miniature in 17 moves
and in case you missed it I'm going to
quickly show you that fun game that we
had which kind of set the tone and
showed us the kind of Chess we were
going to witness with these players
because there style is just so
uncompromising and anyone who's got any
doubt about whether Daniel has it in him
to make a comeback after yesterday take
a look at what happens when you make a
small mistake the guy gives you no
chance at all I'm going to bring that up
just give me a
second all right so it
was just one
sec and we have it here all right and
this was the game now it was a very very
interesting and a sharp nimzo The Rook
C1 line with white always leads to very
exciting positions and this is when all
hell broke lose now this position
undoubtedly Hikaru does know about
because it's been played in top level
chess several times uh white black has
just gone G5 white has retreated the
bishop to G3 and now here instead of
taking on D5 with the queen which is
which is the right way to play Hikaru
takes the D5 Pawn back with the Knight
the point of taking the pawn back with
the queen is that black has already made
concessions along the king side there
are a lot of weaknesses here so he's got
to play really fast to activate the
queen bring it in the center also making
sure that this bishop does not get out
very easily because of attack along the
along this uh along this diagonal on the
G2 Pawn as well as eyeing the A2 pawn
and that is what had to be done he went
wrong playing Knight D5 and after this
basically Daniel dubov gave him no
chance at all and what I really liked
about this game was it shows the
importance of time and Tempo and power
of attack not caring about what's going
on with peace balance take a look at how
Daniel developed this attack he goes
with E3 because he wants to develop the
bishop Queen A5 putting pressure on the
C3 Knight but white just doesn't care
because Bishop D3 the the point is that
all of Black's pieces are already on the
queen side the king is extremely weak
there are a lot of weaknesses along the
king side Daniel's making his imp his
intentions very clear he's going for the
mate already Hikaru played rook d8 and
he simply castles with the idea to
perhaps break with
F4 and something else as well the queen
is soon going to join the attack on H5
here Hikaru took the Knight on C3 and of
course our first instinct would be to
Capt the Knight back with a move like
takes on C3 but here Hikaru would have a
chance to go back to defense you don't
with Bishop f8 what you don't want to do
is take on C3 because then Queen H5 is
disaster but after Bishop f8 the bishop
comes into defense Bishop comes to G7
things are under under control but
Daniel showed us how it's done Knight C3
no time to to grab that piece back he
goes for Queen H5 threat is Queen H6 and
M along the 7
Square after Queen H5 Bishop f8 was
played because if you go Knight D5 now
he simply takes back on he simply takes
on H6 threatening Bishop 87
mate the just to demonstrate how this
tactic works is you don't want to make a
move like A6 but let's take a look at
how it's m Queen here King moves and
queen F7 runs into Checkmate after Queen
86 to stop the threat along along the H7
Square black has the option to go F5 but
then white hits with a very deadly blow
on C8 you take here and basically white
wins the house so after Bishop f8
defending the 87 86 very critical Pawn
Daniel simply took on C3 the threat is
Bishop C7 folking the queen and the Rook
to stop that Hikaru went E5 but it's
really too late because the position has
already fallen apart and here Daniel
played Bishop C4 again not caring about
the pieces not thinking about how to
defend them but just Counterattack
because the king is so weak on F7 is the
big threat you can't take on D4 because
after Queen F7 king h8 queen G8 is M
Hikaru to defend that when Queen C7 and
17th move game over just a brilliant
move by Daniel wrapping it up with
Bishop E5 the point is of course Queen
E5 runs into Queen F7 and the mate that
we just saw happens on the board you
can't really fight against it if you go
Queen E7 White's got Queen G6 taking
advantage of this pin and black runs
into mid and that was the 17 move
miniature that started the match Hikaru
bounced back from it game two could have
got could have been Daniel's game he
made one mistake at the very end and
Hikaru just being an absolute Beast took
use made use of that finished the game
on the spot and that game made me think
about what a heartbreak chess can be
because you play so many good moves
right and you create your chances which
is what Daniel did in game two with the
black pieces and then one mistake and it
all falls apart it's an unfair game a
very difficult game and when you make
these mistakes against a player like
Hikaru Nakamura there's no bouncing back
game three was a master piece by Hikaru
eventually Hikaru went on to win the
match in the blitz portion just a blockb
epic start day one we could not nine out
of 13 decisive games we really could not
have hoped for more more action the
players of course are fighting in the in
a best of five format in the
semifinals uh the one to win the first
three sets advances to the finals and
every every match consists of four rapid
games 15 minutes plus 10c increment if
that's a tie we move on to two Blitz
Games with a 5 minute three SEC plus 3
second time control and if that's a tie
still we go on to the decider Armageddon
this has been a tremendous store so far
and the way the semis started in this
final I think it is going to be an
absolute treat to watch because all of
us have been thinking and it's been on
our mind that is Magnus Carlson
stoppable can anyone come in his way
he's been bulldozing his way through the
entire event with dingin when the world
number three is back in Action Magnus
it's it's not going to be easy for the
world champion and that's exactly what
we saw yes
today and of course chess 24 is also
extremely proud of the event of the
Magnus Carlson chest of final supporting
Kaa Kaa is an organization that does
micr lending to small businesses to
entrepreneurs uh to to thrive and these
are these are businesses which are in uh
underserved communities in isolated
places so they've been doing that since
2005 and they have gone they've done
they've gone another level during the
pandemic mic with their response to
raise money during this time for these
businesses that have been hit by
covid-19 and chess 24 who's done so much
with chess during this time giving us uh
this incredible tour for our for our
entertainment has partnered up with Kaa
and 50% of all memberships during the
finals will go to K's response of the
pandemic to raise money for these
businesses that have been hit by by the
by covid so if you have been thinking
have been on the fence about going
premium do consider doing that right now
because you get access to not just an
just un unlimited access to some
brilliant resources to improve your game
there are video courses by world
champion Magnus Carlson video Resources
by world champion vishan Anand by
Grandmaster Yan Gustafson by Grandmaster
Peter swidler an incredible library to
improve your game you middle game
opening end game all of that but you
also become a part of Premium only
benefits like being able to
challenge great players in Banta Blitz
be a part of Q&A and just all the
benefits that come with the premium
membership and not just that you get to
do that by supporting the community so
uh and yesterday we had Peter tell us
how he has also contributed to this
cause by giving away te by contributing
€1,000 and giving away premium
memberships to talents across Hungary
and this is his contribution to K's uh
uh to the great work that is done by Kaa
so really no better time to think about
supporting chess ensuring that we're
able to keep doing what we're doing and
chess 24 can bring such events to all of
us and also supporting the community
while we do
that uh and I think this is the reason
why very aptly for this this final this
epic final our official hashtag is
impact chess because chess has had such
a positive incredible impact on our
lives during this very challenging time
and now we're using chess to impact the
community in a big Way by supporting Kaa
uh so yes definitely also connect with
us support chess support the community
and connect with us using the hash
impact chess on Twitter let's take a
look at the conversations that we've
been having having on Twitter with all
of you because there was some
interesting stuff and we had Leon WR
writing in with revenge of the ding what
a breathless first day this is going to
be a brilliant tournament and it is wide
open anyone can win and I think that's
the whole point I think so far it's been
a Magnus Golson show but finally his 19
match winning streak came to an abrupt
halt when ding Len found his farm and
showed us why he is world number three
let's move on to the next
one we had Alberto menoa writing in
congratulations to all four players in
the impact chess St finals they have
played such a high quality chess even in
these rapid time controls I think this
is one of the this reminds me of
something that Gary said that the
difference the difference between the
world's best players and good players is
that the amount of mistakes that they
make even rapid and Blitz is so limited
the quality of play of theirs in Rapid
and Blitz and classical is actually very
similar and I think we saw that
yesterday uh there were there were
positional ideas there were plans there
were brilliancies that one feels you
would need time to think on and you're
absolutely right Alberto that even with
short time on the clock these guys are
absolutely phenomenal let's move on to
our next tweet we had Jonathan writing
in a dubo Nakamura rivalry is nice but a
ding but a ding Hikaru ending to this
would be amazing and something new to
see you know what if you would have
bought this up Jonathan before yesterday
I would not have bet my money on that
but with the way things happen yesterday
really anything anything is is possible
as Leon said the field is wide open all
right let's move on and we had Yan
writing in with absolutely this game
will Adorn literally any collection of
best games of any player it's good that
some other games still remind us why
they are only humans and Yan was talking
about um about the end game that
happened in game four in Daniel dubo
Hikaru Nakamura matchup where Daniel was
in a must-win situation and he played a
brilliant a brilliantly instructive and
held literally an endgame masterclass
for us I'm going to quickly actually
show you guys how that went because
I was super impressed with that let me
just bring that up for all of
us all right here we have it now this
entire end game was actually played
really nicely by Daniel he had some he
managed to create chances and he was in
a must win situation he was uh trailing
it was 2-1 was the score going into game
four so to go into tiebreak he needed to
win this game it and throughout the
ending this nigh ha here had gone all
over the board creating threats just
brilliantly played but I think this was
the point that impressed me the most so
uh Daniel has just made the move King G7
Hikaru trades on B7 makes a very
important move B4 the point is that you
take away all the squares from the
Knight and you're threatening to win it
with a move like Rook B8 because the
knight's trapped after B4 Daniel just
finds a stunning counter idea take a
look at what he does he goes Rook H3
checking the king king moves to G2
pushes the king further to the side and
go goes Rook B3 attacking the B4
Pawn Hikaru attacks the Knight and Rook
B4 and now you're like wait a minute the
Knight is lost it's a pin you can't move
so what is it that Daniel had in mind
and he just has this amazing
construction that he comes up with Rook
B6 a very important move because you
want to make sure it's the bishop that
grabs the Knight and not the rook and
take a look why because now the bishop
is forced to take the Knight Daniel goes
Rook B3 cutting off the king from
advancing to towards the H Pawn and if
you take a look at this it is impossible
for white to get rid of this pin anymore
and he's just completely stuck with
nothing to do on the board here Hikaru
went King G2 he can only make moves with
the king the king comes to F6 black has
to be careful to not walk into any check
so that the pin is maintained and after
King H2 H3 simply taking away the G2
Square as well here Hikaru just there's
nothing much to do went rook d8 and gave
up the bishop but really the only other
option was to go King G1 and black would
force white into doing the same thing
with this position and now if you see
White's got literally no moves to save
the bishop has to move the Rook losing
the bishop instead Hikaru went rook d8
and after grabbing The Rook the bishop
on B7 gives up this Pawn but doesn't
matter because you get the F4 pawn and
Daniel converted this without any
problem two versus one
really beautiful instructive play Yan
you're absolutely right this one is one
for the books and with that let's move
on to our next tweet that we had just a
second right so we had Edward writing in
with Magnus Carlson needs to turn up the
heat today can he do it or is ding
Carlson's Kryptonite
and I do see that we've got yasa with us
I was hoping he was here because I think
this is the point that I have to get in
Grandmaster yasa in yasa welcome thank
you very much Tanya hello everyone nice
to join you and thank you for joining
us yes uh let's have that tweet up again
about ding could possibly be could
possibly be Magnus Carlson's Kryptonite
now yes you were at the sinkfield cup
when ding created history by being the
first player to beat Magnus Carlson in a
playoff what do you what do you have to
say to this well if anybody can do it uh
certainly ding is the player and yes in
St Louis uh for the SFI cup Magnus
didn't make any excuses he really said
that you know ding simply played better
it was a
morning uh playoff so maybe Magnus did
have a decent excuse but having said
that Ding played a phenomenal match in
St Louis that playoff and uh he did it
again yesterday I mean we had some
technical issues and we can't discount
the fact that Magnus did overstep in a
position where he wasn't losing but
having said that Ding played amazing and
we were all watching kind of holding our
breath along with Hikaru Nakamura and
Hikaru himself said ding just played a
fantastic Armageddon uh to win the
match absolutely yes I think we were all
thrilled with what happened yesterday I
think it also makes everything a little
more exciting I mean Magnus Carlson is
undoubtedly the best player in the world
right now but when you know that you
know there is competition and he is
beatable I think that's what brings uh
brings hope to others but also makes the
entire competition a lot more thrilling
to watch but if there's anyone who's
known for his comebacks it's of course
Magnus himself and I would I would say
that despite losing the first set in the
match I I think Magnus is still a
favorite in this match but of course
today go on yasa you were GNA say
something oh I agree I I still see him
as a favorite and this might be just
kind of like the slap that wakes him up
but you know as we said it before uh
Tanya chess is a game of confidence and
19 game mini match streak just got
snapped uh and if before the match ding
knew that you know he was the underdog
you know with a maybe a puncher chance
or something like that but now he just
felt feels great like wow I I won I beat
Magnus and I did it over many many games
I can play with this guy and the last
thing Madness wants is a confidence in
opponent but we will see I mean you were
just about to say that Magnus bounces
back uh fantastically well he's done it
throughout his career uh I I would still
say he's a
favorite and as we all saw we are also
joined by Grandmaster Peter Leo he is
with us um and just a quick reminder I
think we're about to have lift off
really soon a quick reminder to all of
you to connect with us using the hashtag
impact chess and be engaged and be a
part of the Magnus Carlson Chester
benefiting Kaa finals uh the bar that
you see at the bottom of the broadcast
you'll be seeing it once the game is on
that is I think a really exciting uh bar
because it tells us how much all of us
as a chess Community have raised for Kaa
to support chess to support the
broadcast to support what chess 24 does
to improve our own chess but most
important importantly to support the
community and help it bounce back from
an extremely difficult time and let's
get Peter on board and Peter I want to
ask you yesterday what impressed you
more was it dingler and finding his form
after a disastrous Legends of Chess and
really showing why he is why he is
considered one of magnus's biggest
challenge or was it Hikaru Nakamura
bouncing back after a horrendous game
one a miniature 17 move game and the
epic fight we had
yeah hello Tanya hello yaser very nice
to be here hello everybody yeah it was a
fantastic first day but I don't agree
exactly that Ding had a disastrous
Legends tournament because he did have
it but in the last round he beat me and
he beat me very confidently with a
perfect play you know and I felt like
the tournament should have started right
now for Ding and it looks to me like
dink has taken his form to to this
tournament from that very last game very
last match for against me and yesterday
he played brilliantly and I also feel
there is a lot of
psychological fight going on there
because if Magnus would have controlled
the match and would have won quite
easily then I think this Factor would
not come alive but let's not forget that
by beating yachi in the finals Magnus
made sure that Ding is here in the
finals and uh this is a very very
specific situation because imagine
Magnus losing today and he goes down 02
and he's on the verge to be eliminated
and suddenly in the night he wakes up
and he says come on but the guy should
not even be here if I would have not
beaten Yan and this is fighting with
your own demons and I wonder whether
after losing yesterday the first set
does this cross magnus's mind or not it
would have definitely crossed mine in in
in this situation so it's another
challenge but if Magnus takes charge and
he wins today he bounces back then I
think that's the way to push this demon
away absolutely Peter and also we would
want to thank you for your generosity in
uh uh in your contribution towards
towards Kaa and also bringing premium
membership to to the talent across
Hungary and supporting chess and the
community like that you're absolutely
right about uh about Magnus anding and
the psychological play around that and
let's not forget it is a best of five
and not a best of three like we have
seen previously on the tour a best of
five means that the player to to win the
first three sets will go forward and as
Hikaru himself pointed out this gives
them a lot of chance to actually bounce
back and try out different things also
the reason why I think we've been seeing
such Dynamic play from the word go and
we do have we do have liftoff so I'm
going to hand it over to yes and Peter
to take us through uh game one thank you
Tanya and hello Peter and we have a
sikov tell us about this uh first game
between Hikaru and Danel Peter yeah this
is very very interesting because I
remember yesterday we're already talking
about magnos playing the sikov and how
effectively he has done it but exactly
yesterday we have seen a mix between nid
off and sikov and that didn't really
work out that well for Magnus now we see
a completely classical uh
I used to have not hundreds but lot of
lot of games with white and with black I
used to be I was considered one of the
main experts but it was like 15 years
ago of course the strategical ideas
remain the same but engines has
influenced many many move PA move lines
even more and it's very interesting that
while we are already having
some main position the sashik of the
Magnus cars and dingly ran match has
just started exactly they played like
one or two moves and it's fast and
furious in Hikaru versus Danel if you
could just kind of sketch uh out in the
position between Hikaru and Danel for a
moment uh what are the I I I want to say
goals of the players yeah well actually
there are many many goals right here in
this position okay one of the main asset
of white is of was this powerful knight
on D5 but if you look at the position
you also see that white is not yet
developed so black is kind of one tempo
ahead and this one tempo plays a very
important role because if white managed
to settle in and stabilize his position
then white will be better and black will
make sure that this extra Tempo will
give him enough counterplay not to let
White's perfect setup happen and we see
Bishop takes A6 happened and Castle
blitzed out by dubov I'm pretty sure
that duo is still following preparation
because this is one of the main lines
I'm not sure if Hikaru had really
anticipated this exact variation or even
the sniko for today's match because
yesterday he was facing the Rouser from
from Daniel but to be honest before the
match before the whole final started I
think if Hikaru did prepare for for Dan
and that's for sure the case then he
must have had snik on his agenda very
good and like you say I mean White's
play is based around the great knight on
D5 and uh in such positions um uh Peter
uh you and I I think we both like to
sacrifice exchanges ideas like Rook
takes
A4 um are on on on wh's uh radar and
where does Black's counterplay usually
come from yeah exactly I mean just to to
highlight two moves moves back after
Bishop D7 I think this was the position
where couple of years ago or some 10
years ago the Thematic exchange
sacrifice with Rook takes A4 was
considered to be the main move and then
black was coming up instead of taking
the exchange because that would simply
Grant white Forever access to the D5
square with the Knight nothing can
really touch it and somehow this B4 Pawn
Knight on D5 and the lights Square
Bishop the pawn on A6 is is falling any
moment uh simply the position was very
very unpleasant for for black but the
point was that after luk takes A4 black
came up with the resource of playing A6
A5 I don't want your exchange I want to
destroy your structure if now you take
this Pawn with B takes A5 then black
gets access to the B2 square and
suddenly a lot of activity for black and
if you take with Rook on A5 then black
has The Counter Strike with Rook takes
B4 and if you take with the Knight on B4
then black takes the Rook on A5 and
again the game becomes Dynamic and you
have the two Bishops so it's in your
favor plus even white is pinned so the
Thematic reaction would be to play
something like
B5 but uh okay first of all now this B5
Pawn is hanging the the point is that
somehow uh ah now I know because Bishop
D7 this explains everything that Bishop
D7 used to be the move which was
considered not to be so precise and then
the move castles appeared ah yes I have
this is the trick yeah castles Rook
takes A4 and now this line like A5 B5
Bishop D7 was very very important Knight
comes back to C3 protecting the pawn on
B5 and now just give white one more move
Bishop C4 which happened in one of my
Blitz Games Against rajabov in 2013 in
sportac in China and white gets total
control but black has the stunning
resource D6 D5 which was played by Sasha
G against Dominguez in Bilbo 2014 that
was a stunning novelty I actually
happened to to know that already one
year before but D6 D5 officially was
played by by Gluk against Dominguez so
all this is behind so you pointed out
very nicely that this Rook takes A4 and
also action sacrific hang in the air but
Hikaru said okay you played Bishop D7
this Pawn on A6 which is often
disturbing white with A5 let me let me
just grab it and now we are seeing that
what happened yeah some King
h8 yeah Bishop C4 yeah we we left here
King h8 B3 white exchanges a takes B3
Queen takes BC and queen E8 played
so uh judging the position if white gets
enough time it should be slightly better
but black wants to get counter play with
F7
F5 wow if you don't mind I feel what I'm
going to do immediately after the this
broadcast is take this clip that we just
had and make a chessable course on this
F the
C we'll make a fortune together Peter
this was great thank you for that
Exposition uh take us over if you would
please to the other uh semi-final
matchup yes just before I go there we
have seen one move that after short
Castle black Play Bishop d8 and this is
exactly the other idea behind queen8 Sid
stepping that not just black TPP as F7
F5 break in the future but the bishop
heads to B6 to the to the diagonal of A7
G1 and if the black Bishop gets there
then it's it gives him stability and
should be very close of equalizing so we
will keep an eye on this game but now
it's time to go to the Magnus game just
as you mentioned let's jump in there and
look at this tell me what you think
about it yes sir uh please tell me how
we got here first of all Peter this is
quite quite quite a position Yes
actually this is some kind of a
relatively modern Theory I wonder what
will be your opinion because uh I
remember I I saw this only in the last
10 years that people suddenly started
playing this line with with the black
pieces so this is like the semit tarash
with C5 but after C takes D5 instead of
the typical Knight takes D5 which is
very popular nowadays all the old way of
playing the tarash E takes D5 black
started to use this move
CD4 so what is your guess here what what
do you say yes sir uh Queen I mean I
actually had a couple of games um
but pre-computer age and I always
thought that the move C takes D4 was a
bit wrong because of Queen takes D4 so I
would have said Queen takes D4 yes e
takes D5 and now Bishop G5 H Bishop G5
yeah but probably in Bishop G5 many
things must have happened I'm I'm not
really into the details but I do know
that lately in the last couple of years
white exclusively plays this position
with E2 E4 so that's why I'm just
guessing that computers must have come
up with some Dynamic for for black in
the lines that you indicate with Bishop
G5 which would be the classical reaction
yeah right I have the impression that I
actually played a game with Judith pogar
I can't remember it very well but Bishop
E7 E3 Knight C6 Bishop B5 castles I
believe was my game with Judith uh from
a long long uh while ago uh but um yeah
I now now that you mentioned it E2 E4
has become the modern answer to this
variation yes yes exactly basically it
automatically reinforces some end game
which looks very nice for white the only
problem is that often the very nice end
games can be analyzed till the end from
the from the weaker side so it's it's
difficult to I mean to to come up with a
surprise but I think that Magnus had
something in his in his sleeve because
uh ding started to to spend time so
Knight C6 Bishop B5 pin D takes E4 black
takes on d8 King takes d8 yes black won
a pawn but he lost the right to Castle
so white goes with Knight G5 black has
to play Bishop E6 which looks like a
very awkward move to make since white
can any moment trade this bishop for the
Knight and one can argue that afterwards
Black's Pawn structure is damaged white
will be able to win back the pawn and
should be better yes exactly that's the
classical way of thinking but in the
process of collecting this Pawn there
are too many Exchange changes and those
are the positions that at home actually
black can maybe analyze Ste the draw and
Magnus said no thank you I mean I have
some surprise for you and Bishop F4 I
think this is a move I I can't really
recall it seems like a very ambitious
move because white does not want to take
back the pawn but go for long castles
right yeah and now that you mentioned it
I do believe that uh there was a game of
Wesley so and Maxim charlot grv that
went many many moves after Knight takes
E6 and uh uh Fe Bishop G5 and Bishop B4
um it just as you say it's like the
weaker side in these end games can
analyze them you
know very very very specifically so
Bishop F4 looks like a very ambitious
move indeed after all if Magnus can get
in uh castles with chck and make
the the black's King's life a little bit
awkward well he's got something to look
forward to but King E7 okay
unfortunately Bishop D6 is premature the
bishop on B4 is still defending D6 but
the king it's strange it looks like it's
on a open Highway and vulnerable but
maybe not so vulnerable uh
Peter yeah it's a I think very move pair
move because Magnus played the move A3
we have a lot of updates because some
Force lines started here Bishop takes CC
and just as you mentioned Bishop D6
check now comes and uh that's the whole
point of forcing The Exchange on C3 so
black had to retreat to E8 Bak C3 had
been played Black forces finally because
it it might look like white anyway wants
to take on E6 but no the point is that
the black king is stuck on the eight and
don't forget the king already moved so
black is not able to Castle long and uh
black needs some Loof and by playing H6
he makes sure that white has to capture
on E6 and after F Tak C6 he gets access
to the F7 qu for for his king that's
very
important it's strange yesterday I
didn't have that great impression that
the games were you know re really heavy
Theory but these two games in particular
really do seem to be uh theoretical
battles
yeah absolutely I mean uh people should
never be fooled by that that the players
leave Theory or not it doesn't mean that
they don't know their Theory just there
is always this certain um nice uh
feeling that when your opponent goes
somewhere you want to react and
yesterday we have seen that the first
game with the Nido went hardly long for
for Magnus probably he did not really
expect ding to play E4 against him
and after that he switched to to the
caran and basically I felt like
yesterday both of them were on little
bit like new grand of course they know
the theory but they simply did not
expect for this match that to happen and
they had to adjust themselves during the
match yes exactly Rook D4 what happened
next uh Peter yeah King F7
played and now the big question is yeah
white has a very nice position but black
kept the pawn and black is about to
connect the Rooks how you collect the
pawn back do you want to collect the PA
back or how you keep your initiative
going well uh to my mind uh you know
it's the double Pawn so I don't really
have this terrible terrible feeling that
I'm a pawn down so I would probably from
White's point of view want to play
something strategic like uh maybe double
pulling the Rooks on the dile and
playing C4 to keep the knight from
D5 and then just kind of asking black
what he will do uh to create play and
maybe on a good day the bishop will slip
back to C5 and I can somehow maybe use
uh the possession of the dile uh
otherwise if I go Bishop E5 Bishop F6 I
don't feel that that's the most ambiti
way for white to to to go forwards in
the game yeah exactly I mean that's uh
that was the the point what I also
wanted to say right from the beginning
that yes the pawn doesn't really matters
I mean white can make a draw whenever he
wants and Rook HD1 Rook hd8 played the
only question is how to try to get more
than than just a draw and I'm pretty
sure that Magnus is searching for that
that pet and what you describe with this
CC and then maybe even just King C2 King
C3 right just to improve and let black
decide please show me how you want to
get out of your misery because you have
the phone but you don't really have
moves exactly I like the way you said
the misery too because uh wolf Anderson
also had this uh brilliant way of using
the word miserable you have a miserable
position it's it's a miserable yes C4
King C2 King C3 and maybe some squeezing
to be done there how is Hikaru and Danel
doing yes so I think that's much more
concrete let's jump in there so we left
after Bishop d8 so yeah and after B5
which uh is not exactly a pawn sacrifice
because if black would capture the pawn
on B5 with Bishop then white simply pins
The Rook along the B file and black will
lose material after Bishop takes C4
black can white can capture on B8 so
taking on B5 is not really an option but
as we already discussed black has two
options bringing the bishop to B6 or to
play F5 now if he brings the bishop to
B6 I think the idea of Hikaru was that
now it's the time to exchange it and to
have the move maybe L A6 which would be
very very unpleasant to face with black
because you don't get your typical
blockade and white is just in time to to
keep the initiative
going it's a very powerful variation to
be sure Peter yes so that's why black
changes his plans and says that yeah
okay you are progressing here let me get
my cter play going with F5 he takes F5
and a big surprise ah okay now
everything is clear now black captures
on B5 pointing out that if you rely on
the same method as we described before
it just does not work because finally
here the Knight on D5 is is hanging okay
of course there is no need to to capture
on B8 but if you take on C4 then I can
take on B1 takes and probably take on F5
and it does look scary that you might be
pinned on the on the eight rank on the
other hand probably black can just
return with the rook and uh you have a
nice position but it doesn't really go
anywhere black is solid enough and the
pawn up and the pawn up that's very
important otherwise give white a Pawn on
e4 and it's a it's
miserable definitely maybe more than
that
yeah yeah yeah but of course yeah after
he takes F5 hearu played Rook fd1
basically making sure that you cannot
really exchange so easily because now
the Knight is protected on D5 right so
the samees doesn't work on the other
hand black is also not really feeling
the need to to exchange the light spread
Bishops because he would prefer to keep
them the only problem is that okay the
look on B8 is hanging and Daniel came up
with a very very interesting Bishop H4
move wow yeah that's a
surprise yeah the the reason I think why
such moves like Bishop H4 are surprised
is that uh it it feels like it doesn't
do that much because from from the white
side you say okay come on you cannot
really be serious that you are hitting
me on F2 pawn and this you really
believe this will hurt me no I will deal
it the way as I want but on the other
hand it it does force white to do
something and now we see that most
importantly black connected his his
heavy pieces so the look on be is not
hanging anymore and in fact black is
tricking that it looks like he's eyeing
F2 but he actually wants to move move
his Bishop back to to D7 or to C6 iaru
say no no I mean I'm not falling for
your chipo my friend let me let me
exchange these light for Bishops as
quickly as possible and Bishop takes B5
had been played yes uh always when you
have a bishop Knight versus Comin
combination versus the two Bishops one I
think the key themes is to eliminate
your opponents to Bishops and I
completely agree with you that uh
strategically speaking Bishop B5 to D7
was some kind of a strategic threat and
to recapture with the bishop on F5 but
now we're here Peter uh to how do I put
it these old classical eyes I'm looking
at a good night versus bad Bishop uh
scenario or is it such a bad scenario
for black well that's also my impression
I mean as a sikov player if I would not
be sure that this is my analysis from
the black side and I know how to solve
the problems exactly move per move then
I would really be worried but I think
here the the the key is that the Knight
on D5 is little bit loose and the pawn
on F5 is hanging and black will combine
the fight against the Knight on D5
thanks to the Rook on B5 which hits the
D5 and also probably the black queen
will join the party with F7 eyeing the
D5 and the F5 Pawn let's Ste not forget
about this bishop which is hitting F2 so
whenever F5 Pawn Falls there's a direct
threat also on the F2 pawn and now white
has to combine uh I mean find a way how
to combine fighting against all these
ideas from from black side that's why I
feel that this is a critical moment and
hiar is rightly taking his time right
and I'm looking at this position Peter
and I'm thinking to myself uh oh I do
eyeball a knight C7 kind of fork so the
moment I move my queen I've got this
thread of Knight C7 so I see uh that I
can move my queen to attack the bishop I
can go Queen H3 or queen C4 and one of
those two moves would get my immediate
attention how about you yeah
absolutely but Hikaru chooses the third
one with Queen A4 but the same
[Music]
idea the same idea and probably also
hinting that I want to you know I I have
nothing against changing the Queens
because then my king will be totally
safe and in fact believe me this in an
end game the black king on h8 can be a
real Target if for example just imagine
some penetration from the Rooks to the
seventh rank I mean uh all this G7 H7
with this powerful knight on D5 can be
really weak so Queen A4 I I like this
move a lot it look it's it's looking
like a a comfortable Advent bandage for
Hikaru and somehow maybe I'm just kind
of hypnotized maybe mesmerized by the
play of Magnus Carlson because he does
somehow he doesn't have to suffer when
he makes the draws in his brand of
playing this FES nikov this frankly to
me feels like a little suffering on the
black side how deep is that suffering
well we're going to find out but it does
feel like whites for Choice okay one
question is can black play Queen
C6 that is maybe a very important
question so if I take the bishop and you
take my knight Queen E7 is not the end
of the road you still have for example
King
G8 yes yeah I feel like I have I have
couple of options I don't know
exactly uh what is the best way can I
also play guki or that's too dangerous
uh two Rooks versus the queen I would ah
sorry sorry yeah yeah of course you take
me check but also Queen F yeah but
otherwise yeah this queen E7 is really
unpleasant something some some suffering
yeah we're gonna be doing a lot of
suffering today I think we better get
out we better get away from this world
word uh so you think Queen C6 is is
necessary I no I mean queen C6 would
have been nice but yeah this queen E7
was really disturbing and I didn't feel
like I will find the force draw there
and I lost interest So Daniel went back
all the way to d8 basically dealing with
the problem of losing the bishop or the
hanging Bishop plus the threat of Knight
C7 but uh it's also a little bit passive
and as you said uh the move Queen A4 was
really uh set up I hearo to go for a
favorable Queen trade which is what it's
exactly what he's done now with the move
Knight C3 he's ready to trade queens and
D6 Pawn is potentially vulnerable and by
the way the Knight on D5 it's a
beautiful piece and I I always liked
Walter Shan Brown he had this great line
he said you know make a picture it's
beautiful but what does it do con
contrarily a knight on e4 will hit the
D6 pawn and it'll do maybe even more
damage so I like the move Knight C3 and
I feel that this is putting pressure on
black absolutely I mean what I just
wanted to highlight one of the ideas
behind Queen C6 was that if you move the
Knight for example you try to be tricky
with Knight C7 trying to force me to to
lose something then I have the Contra
strike with Bishop takes F2 check that
that's actually the idea behind Queen C6
and all of a sudden I'm hitting you on
G2 gotcha
nice but I mean your sense of danger
immediately refuted my whole dream
scenario and after Queen C6 just taking
on H4 and and going Queen E7 that's uh
that's old school effective old
school really really unpleasant but okay
now after Bishop d8 Knight C3 Rook A5 it
does I fully agree that black is
fighting for his life exactly uh it's
speaking of old school
it was this great line bent Larson uh
was telling me now I have to remember it
might have been GID and stalberg they
were playing a game and bent was
fighting for his
life uh and he was really desperate uh
so desperate in fact that he sacrificed
a pawn to get into a bishops of opposite
color position where he was likely even
to lose a second Pawn but bent was
hopeful that he could draw the game and
and afterwards he is lost and he has
complained to his
opponent uh why did you allow me this
chance cried bent Larson there's Bishops
of opposite color I I you
know you help me and uh his old school
opponent said to him but good but young
man don't you know in such end games I
can never
lose that's exactly what we need yeah I
fully agree yeah I can never lose with
the Bishops color and game two pods up
okay uh how bad is this ending for Danel
if we just continue old school style
take take a 94 uh Peter yeah takes takes
94 I guess one of the questions but I
mean it's such a unpleasant position
that while talking it's not so easy to
to save this position one needs full
full concentration and we are seeing
this position on the board uh Knight E4
yeah I don't know because those kind of
Rend games after Bishop B4 Knight takes
D6 black cannot pin the Knight because
of Knight F7 check of course so black
has to take take and it's not the
typical for ver of three no and exactly
this position we could have got from our
variation when we saw this queen E7 I
could have taken for example on D1 takes
go Queen E8 and I felt like I did not
even want to to ask you about this end
game anymore because it looked too
depressing exactly also just to note
that Rook E6 sometimes might force a
king and fwn end game which is as you
say too depressing uh it made me laugh a
moment there Peter because I think uh
you and I uh are clever enough that when
we're at a at a chess club and we're
making a lecture we give ourselves the
better position so somehow I magically
in our discussion about the game managed
to put myself on the white side I've
asked you Peter how are you going to
defend this position Peter's going to
say any moment let's turn to the other
game yeah I don't want to defend this
position I wanted to offer you this but
the reason why I was not offering is
that two things first of all the plan
that Magnus has done were exactly the
same moves we discussed and on the other
hand you know people might be saying
that aha what Magnus is doing is just
listening to yaser's uh commentary and
following his footsteps you know right
well it's funny you should say that and
I only do this once a broadcast but
really I've asked the producers of the
show the engineers uh multiple times uh
uh the players can't hear the
commentators and they keep assuring me
that they cannot that uh
no they have no sound to us and then
they asked me but but but why do you so
VI so so oftentimes ask I say because
they they play all the moves I've
suggested uh okay uh dingler is he's a
pawn up Peter but is he a happy camper
yeah I don't think he's happy but he's
maybe also not that unhappy look at the
clock situation it might tell us
something I mean Magnus done to less
than three minutes dingl and still has
more than six which means that Magnus is
desperately searching how to get the
Maxum out of this position and by
playing rug B8 to B7 black is not
setting up a threat of uh I have to move
like this yeah Rook A8 try to double the
Rooks and invade on the B file and now
white faces this uh unpleasant situation
that if I want to stop this plan then I
can do it by exchanging one pair of
Rooks but do I really want this because
then it eases Black's life black will
have access to the D7 square with the
Knight later on hitting the Bishop from
C5 and otherwise I can only stop Rook A8
with a move like Bishop D6 but I don't
want to close my Rooks yeah right so
what to do and then magnos spend quite
some time and find the third option by
playing Rook to
B1 but it does not change so much
because Rook A8 Rook takes B7 Rook B7
happened and now Magnus had to make sure
that he prefers this position or the
position after let's say Rook d8 Rook
takes d8 Rook takes d8 yeah if we
compare this position then we see that
in one line white has a rook on D4 which
is probably aimed in order to keep the
Knight on F6 because then The Rook on D4
is eyeing the E4 Pawn that's kind of
what what I'm guessing well also the
idea is that in this position Magnus if
he had played Rook d8 it would be like
he committed himself to the move whereas
exactly in the game position Peter he
could consider Rook D6 exactly and Rook
D6 played you know what it's played yeah
and and it's very nice because Magnus
first played luk D6 and only after it
was mentioned by you without knowing it
so we made sure that everything is under
control with with with all the
technicality of the of the tournament
and that proves that the players are not
cheating by listening to our commentary
yeah definitely which is clearly a joke
but I mean simply it was so nice that we
discussed and it came from you
automatically that you know what I want
to double with L on D one I want to go
C4 restrict the knight from going to D5
then let's walk the king with C2 to C3
so it all made perfect sense I had to
use this opportunity it was such a high
ball I had to use it exactly exactly and
now what do we have because uh Magnus
could take on C6 or Play Bishop D4 just
trying to keep uh tsuji on the Knight on
D7 he took on C6 he took on C6 yeah we
are seeing some for sequence Knight E
five Rook
A6 and now it's a little bit surprising
moment that Ding is taking his time so
it's not to automatically capture on C4
because if he would take on C4 then
white goes King C3 hitting the Knight
and then the pawn on A5 would fall so
maybe some idea with Knight D3 is he
thinking about or Rook C7 interesting
let's go back to the current
position and again it feels to me that
somehow transitioning all the way back
from the opening more or less to this
endgame position um it almost seems like
that bridge uh how deep is the
preparation of the players uh today do
you feel um Peter are they looking from
openings to Middle games and middle
games to
endings I I think definitely they do but
the point is that there is so much
information and there is so much work to
do that basically it's impossible to
remember the things so what the players
are usually relying nowadays I think is
that they have to make sure that they
know everywhere that direction and once
they know that direction they know that
okay we will figure out of figure out
the rest because we know that this is
the direction if if you don't know the
direction then you are completely unsure
you are burning way too much time and
double check and questioning yourself
whether what you think about the
position is right or wrong but if you do
have this feeling that yes I remember
that this was the direction then playing
the position is is much easier and much
more natural right well this position
certainly feels like Magnus for choice
because you were about to say the
options facing black whether they be
Rook C7 or Knight D3 or Knight C4
they're not a none of them really are
attractive
exactly that's why I didn't dare to say
anything
yeah Knight C4 as you mentioned is going
to walk into King C3 the Knight will
have to move again leaving the A5 Pawn
hanging and at the same time uh also
Rook A7 to uh force a very very
favorable trade uh into a minor piece
ending conversely Knight D3 from the
starting position how would that go
Peter it does hit the bishop but
but yeah I think maybe I can just go
Bishop D4 Maybe cover the B2 square and
and I remember this very well it was
sort of like you play Bishop D4 the
opponent plays E5 and then you play Rook
A7 and I remember you know having these
uh analysis sessions with Victor kcho
and he was really really clever about
making me put my Pawn on E5 so that my
knight on D3 was somehow
trapped it was like how did he how did
he conceive those types of things and uh
this is something I mean I know there's
a night1 check in the position too but
these are one of those things that Ding
Lin might be fearful he could get into a
lost minor piece ending very quickly as
well yeah I mean it's it's very tricky
so absolutely understandable that he's
taking his time but he cannot really
think for very long he's done to two and
a half minutes but one idea that came to
my mind was something like T SES and
push the pawn to A4 okay and all of a
sudden I have some kind of a positional
Fortress because your king cannot really
enter you can go go to C4 but I'm I'm in
time to stop you with King D5 of course
you have many other options you don't
have to push C5 but that was kind of one
idea that came to my mind maybe black
could try to it like this I see I see
nice um okay um as
we we won't join Ding and his suffering
how's Dan's suffering going yeah finally
just before we move because after all
ding made up his mind and he took on C4
so he eliminated the C4 Pawn King C3 had
been played Knight B2 was played uh Rook
takes A5 Knight D3 so finally yeah yes
white won the pawn back white has a very
nice position the key defensive idea
from black is that white cannot play
Rook A7 because Knight takes C5 protects
the Rook whoops otherwise of course Rook
A7 would be G over immediately and
thanks to
this white is clearly better in my
opinion but uh black has some hopes to
Ser exactly such a
reduced uh material uh four ponds per
size Rook andish versus rook and Knight
there are drawing chances but definitely
Magnus looks to be in pole position and
again uh boldly stating the obvious
because we don't get a chance to say it
too often we might as well get it in
Magnus trails in the match he lost the
first set and he needs to win today's
sets of matches to equalize the
match yeah and in this respect I have to
say I'm really happy that we have the is
best of five sets because uh it it feels
like it does not put so much pressure on
the players they can really focus on
just play good chess because if you
finally get your Rhythm and you get
going then you can come back after any
result and uh yes he's behind but today
the games are even it's z z and if he
managed to win today's game then
definitely it will uh boost him for for
today's games and if he bounces back
then he gets another confidence so yeah
very important to start well today for
magnos exactly and in Dan's uh game with
hearu how have things developed there o
uh
yes three versus two uh First
Impressions Peter yeah first impression
is that usually three versus two with
Rooks and one minor piece versus look
minor piece is is very unpleasant to
defend one on the other hand if you want
to defend or you have to defend because
you never want to but if you have to
have to defend such position then
probably this is one of the best setups
for black with with this Pawn on H5 G7
and the bishop dark spread Bishop on F6
uh which gives good chances to to hold I
would say this is a typical position
which in former Soviet Union they were
saying okay 50% chances to win 50%
chances to draw nice uh two result game
for sure as you just described it and um
boy I can't say that I've had in my
career that
much um practice in these three verses
too normally if I get them it's just
straight up with the Rooks uh the
addition of the minor piece I feel that
the Knight helps white because uh he can
play on the light light squares with the
knight uh as well as the dark squares
um and that's the X Factor uh if it was
just as you would say uh Rooks a clean
Rook ending then the draw POS quoti
doesn't go 5050 it goes like 90% draw a
10% losing so the the the addition of
the minor piece helps the superior side
yeah absolutely I mean I did have some
of these positions but never with Knight
extra Pawn versus the bishop minus Pawn
I had Knight versus knight and Rook Rook
three versus two jaro in the Dresden
Olympia 2008 it was the very last game
of the chess Olympia it was the last
round and already the organizers were
packing all the other boards and chairs
and whatsoever and I feel like move
hunted I don't know what I'm squeezing
this position and and I can't make any
progress you know in three versus two
and it's psychologically very difficult
because you want to play this position
until your opponent falls out of his
chair and finally he loses and I'm
squeezing squeezing squeezing and after
already running the risk of move 50
without making any exchanges or
whatsoever I D to change one pair of
Pawns so we got to two versus one and
you know what I just won that position
after a couple of moves and then I
understood and I also remembered later
there was a game Kik versus elov in Vian
which also faced this situation that Kik
was pressing pressing pressing couldn't
really improve then he exchanged one
pair of Pawns and he won the game e
easily remarkable story I love this idea
of the organizers happily lifting up
chairs and putting tables away and
you're in this gigantic Hall all by
yourself as there as as workmen are
waiting for the closing
ceremony for you to back up and leave
yeah but actually for me that game was
also very important because by winning
that game I secured gold medal on board
one and it was the most successful
Olympiad for me personally on on board
one of course it's a team event so
usually you challeng much more if your
team does well but since we were not
doing that well I was very happy that at
least my own performance was was great
congrat T so I believe here we will not
really see so much action so the players
will be playing for forever so let's go
back to to the magnus's game
alrighty look at this whoa uh very
unexpectedly suddenly uh black has no
kingside Peter yeah no kingside but some
kind of control in the center but if
there is no Perpetual check or the
domination cannot be really used then it
should be just a method of time till
Magnus converts this by the way time
time uh pressure on the clock is a
factor for both players if you don't
mind if you just take us back to the
position with Knight D3 very quickly and
we'll yes uh D4 Rook C7 check King D2
finally the problem was that probably
black felt if he just sits and wait he
loses anyway so he decided to to go for
activity he gave all his pawns so this
is how we got there I
[Music]
see aha
cuz very interesting yeah
yes because it looks like white is just
collecting and black is jumping jumping
but doesn't really create
anything but look at this ah this is
this is the concept because a couple of
moves had been played yeah King B2 King
D5 look at this uh dingly and cement the
Knight on D4 and makes sure that after
Bishop takes D4 he will always have e
takes D4 with getting some dangerous
passer himself and he tries to force
some some pereto with the Rook but it's
hard to believe that it can work exactly
that H Pawn look like it's just so
fast yeah H5
played then Rook C2 check King B1 Rook B
Rook E2 so black relies on some Knight
B5 Knight C3 idea yeah right this is the
only thing because this is the famous
Perpetual check that the white king
would not be able to go to the corner
because then with the Knight on cly
black would give Checkmate on A2 and
with the King on for example let's just
say H6 Knight B5 and okay you would even
push the pawn because it Queens but all
of a sudden black gets a draw because
you cannot go to A1 because due to the
mate and if King C1 then black has this
typical Eternal check but Magnus says
thank you very much I mean I just going
to stop you from playing Knight B5 with
Rook C7 and Dink has
[Music]
resigned as Michael to famously said the
music has
stopped uh it's that simple uh there was
a threat in the position Knight B5 and
and uh you stop the threat of Knight B5
thanks to Rook C5 check and since
there's no stopping H6 and G5 dingler
and gave it a
rest uh my goodness that was a smooth
Victory it almost felt like somehow from
the opening Magnus had a concept and he
just rode it all the way to Victory
Peter yeah it seems like if you look at
the game then after the the game you
will tell to your students I mean please
take a look how Magnus beat ding Lan
this is exactly the way you should never
ever play against Magnus no because he
excels so much in this type of positions
but I mean uh it it was brilliant
performance because everything had to
fit everything had to be incredibly
precise because if you just give one
half tempo for ding I'm pretty sure that
he would have maybe even relatively
easily save this position but Magnus
just was so precise at least that was my
impression
and it was a it was a wonderful victory
for Magnus very well done as Magnus
takes the first game in today's Set uh
let's go back to our happiness of three
versus two uh Peter yeah so nothing
really changed but still some things
have changed white has activated his
King to the maximum to E4 and push the
pawn to F4 this might sound a little bit
counterintuitive because because white
puts all his pawns on the on the dark
squares and black has a dark Square
Bishop so one could argue that black
Bishop will be able to Target the black
pawns I mean white pawns on the dark
spares but uh these pawns are actually
restricting the the dark Square bishop
and Hikaru has a very very nice plan and
the typical plan in this positions and
we have seen that Rook B5 was played
King F Rook B5 King F7 check King F3
that white somewhere wants to go F4 F5
and say that once I trade the F Pawn for
the G Pawn then this nice little Pawn on
H5 can be a big Target over there right
yeah I exactly and I see that F4 F5 kind
of break really having a great deal of
power when The Rook is also on the G5
Square so that you know you get to go
Rook G5 and F5 uh
it's incredibly
forceful yeah exactly I wonder that
after King G7 was a move like Rook G5
possible or not because I'm threatening
Knight F5 check as well so you have to
react it might look like you have to
move your king
somewhere yeah Rook G5 looks incredibly
strong I'm not
sure what on Earth Danel could have done
um yeah I don't know because you have to
move your king somehow and then I go F4
F5 and if you go luk G7 I take on G6 and
give you a check and the pawn on H5 is
falling not even talking about the rest
so maybe it was a missed opportunity but
I mean it's such a technical position
that I don't believe that uh this chance
will not reappear in the game also let's
not forget the players are very long
time right okay Hikaru has some time but
still once your opponent is done on time
you maybe feel the urge to to play fast
but that that was that was a golden
opportunity with luk G5 it seems sure
looks
so
definitely instead Hikaru played Knight
C4 Rook F7 Rook C5 Rook E7 Rook C6 King
F7 by the way this is such a difficult
def position for the defender to hold
because it's sort of like you can tickle
on the G5 square and if that doesn't
bring success we can bring the to the D5
square and and always you feel as the
defender that you know uh you start to
see more and more ghosts and you're
burning clock how do I hold this
position it's it's a thankless task yeah
absolutely I mean I couldn't agree more
it's practically I think this position
is just lost because without inclement
at least you know that you can fight try
to play very quickly and your opponent
might run out of time but if there is in
and even your opponent has more time
then you really have this impression
that he will keep on playing this
position until you just die yeah I mean
right and maybe you will even be happy
to die finally because it just already
enough is enough yeah yeah stop stop
stop the torture as you said about your
game where you you you you will play
until your Mo falls off his chair
exactly I mean I I remember I had a game
uh from Tessalon uh Olympia
where my opponent the Chinese player um
we adjourned I am not joking Peter like
five times uh it was a queen and pawn
ending I had like Queen in five versus
queen in four for the first adjournment
and then in the second adour I had Queen
and four versus queen and three and it
kept going like
that uh power to my opponent the game
was a draw but in my hometown magazine
in the Pacific Northwest Northwest
chess they they had it as the game that
couldn't devour China and it was like
this Chinese dragon and it had
text uh of the moves in the Chinese
dragon and it was on the top of the
magazine and you open up the magazine
and this Dragon kept going and going and
it was the entire
issue it was like a 200 move game that
was something
ridiculous how is it going now what's
happening Peter yeah I mean it's uh it's
the torture continues let's put it that
way right because yeah bishop
d8 and
then Knight D5 Luke A7 and I was getting
some info extra info from the producer
soteris was telling me that he was there
at this Olympiad he witnessed this
terrible torture and he still remembers
it he has nightmares you know okay
nightmares this is already my ex Edition
but uh I mean he was writing me that the
game started Yas was playing that game a
whole week I was there and actually
watched one of the ederman sessions it
was run three and it finished around run
nine plus three days you
know correct it was my very first visit
to
China and Dr lingang he was the General
Secretary of the Chinese chess
Association and it was oh Mr seran very
very nice to meet you I was the team
captain for the Chinese team in Tessalon
Olympia and I have woken up like five
days in a row at 8 o'clock in the
morning to go to the playing Hall thank
you so very
much you know what you you always had
this reputation because I know that I
was told in my childhood if you want to
know how to torture your opponent
exactly just watch y's games you know I
was thought like this oh oh my
reputation terrible uh and Hikaru uh he
is he's continuing the torture how bad
is it Peter yeah I think his only danger
is that he's not running down on the
clock yeah this is this is exactly the
thing he should not be doing because
this gives Danielle practical some
practical chances to to ES
right and it feels like what hikaro
wants to do is somehow get in two moves
King E5 and F5 somehow simultaneously he
wants to be able to capture or recapture
with the King but he hasn't done that
he's played the move Rook uh C8 is he
trying to dominate the bishop uh well no
maybe he's just trying to win some time
on the clock yeah I think so I mean one
of the psychological issues is that I
mean should you exchange the the Rooks
or not yeah because you only want to
exchange it if you make sure that you
are definitely winning because now black
has this idea of bringing the bishop to
E1 somehow targeting this targeting the
pawn what you mentioned many moves ago
which was that by putting all the pawns
on the dark squares G3 could be
vulnerable but yes sorry Peter please
continue yeah I mean that's why I
thought like his idea is more like try
to dominate and we see some very Force
sequence now King E5 I mean Rook A3
attacking the pawn on G3 King E5 Bishop
A5 played and F5 but I'm not liking this
because maybe too many pawns will be
exchanged G takes
F5 automatic whenever you're the
defender exchanging pawns is the dream
yeah because let's also not forget that
usually Rook Bishop versus Rook is a
practical chance but Rook Knight versus
Rook is zero practical chance so uh
black has real hopes to escape now King
F5 played and I'm just looking at the
uh at Hikaru there and he's he's he's
shaking his head in disgust he feels
that he's let his opponent off the hook
Peter yeah absolutely I mean now we we
we see how important it was that there
was this golden opportunity with L G5
yeah I also saw that the engine bar
suddenly jumped yeah this is this EAS is
for example
the commentator's job when we see the
engine bar jump we automatically
understand that aha there is some
special moment in the game and then once
you are highlighted there is a special
moment it's very easy to spot that ah it
has it had to be this and that
yeah exactly and we do have Rook takes
G3 and there goes a pair of Pawns now
I'm just like you like you say I mean
the best that white can hope for is rook
and Knight versus Rook where you don't
have anywhere near the the great
practical chances that a rook and Bishop
uh provides by the way on that note
Peter does it surprise you when you see
top Grand Masters losing I mean losing
the rook and Bishop versus Rook ending
no not at all not at all because uh you
know there was one moment when I played
against Magnus
in in t Memorial Blitz in 2009 maybe
yeah and and you know it was the time
control three three minutes plus 2
seconds and when we reach Rook Bishop
versus Rook I had something like four
seconds and a very tough game behind me
Magnus had something like 20 seconds I
defended like for more than 30 moves and
uh then suddenly exactly when Magnus was
kind of giving up and he started to
create chances from from scratch again
then I missed something and I lost the
game and I I remember that uh that game
was suddenly then published and analyzed
in chess magazine saying that how come
Leo didn't know how to draw The Rook
versus Bishop I mean I had four seconds
on the clock you know I mean I was happy
not to lose on time it was of course if
you lose it in a classical game and you
have time that's another issue but I
mean all these rapid events or Blitz
events usually the defensive side
reaches that position after some very
hard struggle yeah so he has already
lost lot of energy he's completely
exhausted and so on and then uh to to
lose it it's possible right then then
it's then it's possible but okay let's
uh let's see this game because it's not
over yet yeah it's not not over yet
still they're still going uh but with
this move Rook A1 I see black has the
opportunity of just playing Bishop to
F2 and that looks really easy suddenly
actually Daniel even goes King F7 it's
like he wants to signal that you know
I'm not even scared of this pin show
some confidence yeah because definitely
I just wanted to highlight this position
because to be honest I have never seen
such a pin along the on the first rank
against a black Rook on G1 and the
bishop on E1 it's it's very funny it's
not it's not common that's for sure yeah
and meanwhile yeah basically it was just
probably Hikaru said enough is enough I
had my chance I spoiled it now it makes
all no sense the players exchange
everything and a draw was
agreed okay nice uh nice start and uh
Tanya you're back uh with us as we have
one win for Magnus Carlson and a
draw yes yes indeed which means ding is
left playing catch up now and what a
technical Masterpiece by the world
champion but I have to say that with the
action that we had yesterday I was
missing that Dynamic combative
aggressive play today felt like a
positional master class and I've got
some big news for our audience if you
guys enjoy attacking combative play
which which excites all of us we have a
great deal on
uh
make the most of our resources on the
board intuitively you use our intuition
for sacrifices and also build positions
that allow allow tactics to flow and
basically just play like Alpha zero so
uh there's a great deal on on that with
uh
33% off and not only do you learn how
how to not only do you learn how to
attack like a pro but also 50% of these
sales will go to Kiva so you also
support K's um uh you also support K's
response to the pandemic so definitely
check out Anna rudolf's course on how to
attack like a machine because yes speeda
we're going to have liftoff soon and you
know what great masterpieces great
technique by Magnus Carlson it was the
kind of game that makes you feel where
did ding really go wrong and I remember
we did an interview with Peter where he
said his favorite games are the ones
where it's hard to tell where a player
goes wrong or it's hard to point out uh
an obvious mistake and that's what felt
like in magnus's and ding's game so the
world champion is back uh and looking
for looking for Revenge absolutely with
that with that we're going to pass it on
I think we still have a a couple of
minutes before game starts so perhaps we
could we could hear it from our a
audience what they had to say on Twitter
about the action that's been happening
today on day two of the semi-finals and
again a quick reminder the bar that you
see below me right now is the amount of
money that we as a chess Community have
raised to support to support businesses
to support uh entrepreneurs in
underserved communities which have been
hit by the pandemic to survive uh a very
challenging time so great job on that
and keep going at it and let's see how
fast we can get this bar up we heard
from The elusive Panda and he said
Magnus looks human but it's nice to see
him struggle it makes his winds more
impactful and reminds us not to be too
hard on ourselves yes absolutely and I
think um Magnus has his human moment but
we don't have time for more because we
have lift off yes Peter take it away
thank you Tanya you had me Tanya at uh
learn to play like Alpha zero the 50%
and helping Kea well those are just
bonuses teach me how to play like Alpha
zero Anna I will be very very pleased
Peter we have a Joko
piano yes we we do have a Joo piano and
uh it's very interesting for me to see
how Magnus will react because uh because
we haven't been seeing magnos facing the
J piano so often lately and uh yeah he
he he chooses the A6 setup because I
wanted to say that yeah there are two
different conceptual ideas one is the
move A6 which I'm also more fan of I
mean it's the the classical way of
treating the position but dingan is the
big expert from the black side in
positions like short castles Rook E1 and
playing the move A5 putting the pawn to
A5 it brings completely new Dynamics
because in some positions the pawn on A5
is clearly better than on A6 on the
other hand it weakens this B5 Square
which gives also access for the white
Bishop later to to B5
square and uh this is something like
recent development in the last couple of
years but magnos sticks
to sticks to the classical approach with
A6 and Rook E1 H6 so Magnus makes sure
that no Bishop g5s will ever come in
this game you know Peter I I'm looking
at this exact position and it's I I'm I
in inwardly I'm really laughing I'm
smiling at myself because I remember
having these conversations in the
1970s uh Bobby fiser you know was the
world champion and there's going to have
a challenger and the year
2000 felt very very far away uh but we
would ask ourselves in a kind of a
science fiction you know like what is
the ultimate result of a chess game is
chess of force draw can can white win
and what will the chess of the 21st
century look like like what will be the
most popular variations well computer
computers Force us to completely
re-evaluate our openings and at that
time like every Junior player in America
I really had only one opening the Joko
piano anything that allowed the Mac
slang attack or the fried liver I mean
that was my territory right and now I'm
looking here we are in the 21st century
and the most elite players in the world
all have the Joko piano in their
repertoire I thought the Joko piano was
played out clearly that's not the case
tell us why the elite players are
attracted to it yeah well actually there
had been quite a lot of development uh
since 2015 2016 I think the first Super
tournament where it really came in
crashed into to the scene was the
candidates tournament in Moscow 2016
suddenly players like Anish giri Vish
Anand sge kakin they all started relying
on the on the Italian or Joo piano uh
and uh all of a sudden it turned out
that there is much more to it than in
2016 in the autumn time during the world
championship match between Magnus Carson
and serge karakin in New York Magnus
himself used this very specific line
with A4 I mean this is the new
development that against the A6 setup
white answers it with A4 because the
usual classical scenario was that white
is retreating to to BC with the bishop
and you know it's the typical fashion
there were like two three years where
exclusively A4 was played and then
suddenly last year 2019 we have seen
some period when Bishop B3 took over and
while Bishop B3 was so effective last
year that people already all adjusted to
the A4 setup and all the ideas from the
past in Bishop BC line were kind of
Forgotten or not analyzed in depth uh
not enough depths and uh this is this is
very interesting and now the position
the versus Magnus Carson is very
exciting to me because Magnus is playing
exactly my line and you know I'm
referring to this last round in the
Legends versus ding Lam but it has a
very special moment because ding is
usually a D4 one night F3 or one C4
player right and uh in that last round
he in the very first game played one E4
against me and already during the whole
Legends tournament I had a lot of
Italians and I had very good result
against Vish
I think he's one of the greatest experts
right now in this J piano so I was very
proud that I absolutely show that I can
fight against vishi in his territory and
then all of a sudden ding played the the
Italian and for some mysterious reasons
because probably I was shocked I
deviated from my setup which I know and
the setup is exactly what now Magnus is
playing against ding which I played
against vishy and vishy played against
me because we had reverse colors battles
there and uh I played the line which I
already knew three years ago that it's
bad I simply relied on the fact that
maybe ding is not that familiar with the
position but the point is that he's also
playing it from the black side a lot and
he knew the reputation and he bedzed out
everything just as it was written in my
file in 2017 that it's plus minus only
problem was that I was on the deceiving
side from the black and I just lost
without the fight and he never gave me a
chance to come back nice nice story and
now that you've uh set the table so so
beautifully uh tell us after this move
C4 what Magnus should play yeah actually
I will just come back uh few moves just
to see how we reached here so basically
the uh Magnus is relying on the
classical idea that he just wants to go
Bishop E6 trade of this very strong
light Square Bishop so white goes H3
very typical Bishop E6 six Bishop takes
C6 Rook E6 B4 I mean usually if black
exchanges this light Square bishop and
white gets nothing in return Then black
solved all the problems so white is
claiming that thanks to my queenside
advance I have some something to play
with so B4 Bishop A7 Bishop B2 this is
the move which actually Anish giri
introduced I think last year and uh
there were some followers but also not
that many follow follows vishi himself
played against Anish Bishop B2 in the
armag in the armag game right now in the
Legends tournament so Anish was also
ready to play it from the black side
it's just a very rich position basically
you have to rely on your understanding
because it's not move P move position
and look at this how Magnus reacts very
interesting because after Bishop B2
Magnus immediately goes for his set up
with Knight E7 he wants to bring the
Knight to G6 this is where the Knight
belongs
uh dink said Okay I want to grab space
with C4 also it stops any kind of D6 D5
breaks of course right now after black
move the Knight to E7 Pawn on E5 is
vulnerable but for example with the
Knight on G6 already black would love to
push D6 D5 so white makes sure that this
not this does not happen and Magnus
plays A6 A5
wow that when you say wow that says to
me that that not in your file Peter that
no it is I mean I know the idea but it's
wow because it's it's a surprise and I
also remember that Magnus himself he
used this in one of the grest tours
maybe against kakin three three years
ago four years ago I remember it was
some very little bit older game I mean
where do we stand something like
happening from 2016 or 17 feels like
ages ago yeah
yes it does doesn't it remarkable and
the idea of course behind A5 is to take
away flexibility white may have intended
to play D3 D4 and with the pawn on B4
the C5 Square will be defended but now
after A5 if I play a move like B5 I'm
taking away uh a lot of flexibility and
I'm giving nice squares C5 as you just
properly pointed out
away
um okay uh can he grab the pawn on A5 uh
and say you're GNA have difficulties
recapturing the pawn
Magnus and it have I mean it just
happened exactly in the moment when you
said what happens after ba5 ba5 had been
played and Mos jumps right back and this
is the idea look at this Knight C6 that
I mean that's why I said wow because it
looks like Knight E7 black was heading
towards the Knight G6 plan but just that
white played the move
cc34 anticipating Black's idea of
bringing the Knight to G6 Magnus
immediately senses this moment and he
switches plans and he jumps on the
possibility even if it's a temporary
Pawn sacrifice but he feels that these
squares are very very
important right well again you yeah I'm
just going to type out an email message
to our producers to be absolutely sure
uh the players can't hear
us uh night D7 okay for the pawn
sacrifice as you pointed out a moment
ago the D4 square and the C5 Square are
nicely under Black's
control uh is it absolutely sufficient
uh compensation do you feel um
Peter yeah well it's uh very interesting
because look at this I mean Magnus
reacted in this way I mean basically
also trying to get the respect of his
opponent that you see I mean I'm ready I
have all these deep ideas ready I know I
feel the position but ding instead of
thinking and say wow he says no no no no
no I'm not impressed at all I know all
this and he just played Bishop CC Rook
B1 Knight F1 almost a Tempo signaling
back to Magnus that you know please show
me how confident you are after all you
give the pawn you have a lovely Knight
on C5 but this Knight on C5 while being
very nice it blocks the Bishop from A7
and the Bishop from A7 blocks the Lop
from A8 putting pressure on the A5 on
the A5 Pawn so lot of lot of Dynamics
here and and I can I can easily guess I
always like those positions where I know
my next to moves I know I want to play
Knight G3 and I know I want to play D4
there at after and the fact that this
Rook is on B1 it kind of makes it
awkward for the Knight on C5 to move but
as you say the Knight on C5 it's
blocking the bishop on A7 the bishop on
A7 blocks The Rook on A8 and there's a
bit of a traffic jam uh going on in
Black's position uh whereas White's
position strikes me as a little bit
Freer Peter yeah there is also the idea
of maybe going Knight E3 Knight D5
that's also another route yeah because
yeah that's a nice Square yeah the
Knight on D5 would put a lot of pressure
on the C7 pawn and also would make sure
that whenever the knight from C6 maybe
moves to E7 and to G6 then black maybe
wants to play Move Like C6 taking away
the D5 Square from the Knight if white
jumps towards the D5 square but one of
the things came to my mind that in order
to justify this position black has to
try to be energetic because uh if you
give white time to consolidate then I
don't really believe that you can rely
on positional compensation and Magnus
has played Rook G6 yeah indicating that
yeah yeah yeah I want something against
your king because maybe I can combine
ideas with Knight E6 Knight F4 and once
the Knight moves then all of a sudden
the bishop Comes Alive absolutely and
that Rook G6 move makes a lot of sense
to me Knight G3 would walk into a
terrible tactic like Rook takes G3 that
Bishop on A7 in Ambush I just want to
mention also Peter that the other
semifinal game has started so
um a chess player's Delight I must say
as we've got four of the very very best
chess players in the world uh doing
damage yeah we can just jump in right
there because to be honest I was here
while the Lindor
tournament was played of the grand of
the Magnus chess tour and there was
already a theoretical discussion between
exactly the same players Daniel Duo
against Hikaru Nakamura in the very same
line exactly I was about to say the
player started with 15 minutes no they
didn't they started with 17 as they have
blitzed their way to uh this theoretical
position of the
English this used to be my territory but
interesting yeah I think it's your
territory that's exactly the point I
also wanted to make but to be honest I
feel like they are playing some very
specific Theory right because I don't
really recall so many games so classical
games in this line but between this
players there already happen to be I
think three games in that very
tournament wow okay so uh I I mentioned
in yesterday's broadcast how I find
elite players to be extraordinarily
stubborn individuals and especially
where their openings are concerned I
mean they prepare their openings they
believe in them and they take their
opening ideas with them to the Grave so
sometimes when you see these matchups
they really become uh a personal opening
Vendetta you know how dare you say my
nimzo Indian is a bad defense and it's
it's nice when you see see these top
class uh players have a theoretical
battle I also just on that note I I I
wanted to share another story I thought
was very very
funny because you were saying that
um yesterday ding Len and uh Magnus were
fighting on a territory of the caroan
that was maybe a little bit unexpected
for both players right uh somehow that
was where the match went
there was a match between hikaro
Nakamura and vasil
ivanchuk and you think to yourself well
these two great players man that that
that must have been a f fun match do you
know where the territory it was decided
upon like the match no actually I'm
trying to figure out where and where was
this match at first I I don't exactly it
was it the the the the the fight the
dispute was in the king's
Gambit wow yeah yeah yeah I I do
remember something now yeah yeah and it
was like
what both players preparing for their
opponents had a king's Gambit in mind
and they were switching colors as well
it was like what it was pretty hilarious
okay but what do we have yeah actually
it's it's very interesting because
before we come to the current position
let me just jump back here come back to
this moment after move 13 Bishop takes
F3 I believe in their very first game
black played Rook B8 and got into some
trouble and Daniel won a very important
game against Hikaru then in some other
game uh between them something happened
I mean maybe Queen C8 was played but the
key moment was that uh the pawn
sacrifice C6 also appeared in one of
their games and the very interesting
moment was that after Luke B8 we had
Danielle on in the studio and we asked
him and he said yeah I think Rook B8 is
probably not the best move black should
play something like I don't remember if
C6 or queen C8 and so on so he kind of
invited Hikaru you know that you know I
mean okay I know that C6 Queen C8 exit
come there and it felt like a very
psychological moment and then in one of
the games Hikaru did play C6 sacrific
the p and in fact it turned out that
Daniel was maybe bluffing because he
wasn't EX L ready for for the pawn
sacrifice and Hikaru made a quite easy
draw and in this respect I'm pretty sure
that after this match both players have
done really big work on this line and by
now they probably understand where it is
heading but sometimes when you look too
much it it gets even more
confusing in any case Hikaru went for
the queen C8 setup now right and A4
looks like a very natural reaction as
White's eyeballing an opportunity to
play A5 and A6 which was immediately
stopped yes of course yeah A5 that's
also the idea of leaving The Rook on A8
because in in their game with Rook B8
black exactly faced this problem that A4
A5 was coming connected with some D4
ideas and white was just too active so
yeah Queen C8 A4 A5 white takes on A6
Rook A6 and D4 so very energetic
absolutely abely and uh after this very
consequential move as black I feel like
I absolutely have to play Rook d8 uh any
uh captures on D4 that just kind of
helps white develop his forces yeah and
Rook d8 had been played and Bishop E4
was still blitzed out by Daniel and I
believe it was the first moment in the
game when Hikaru took some time played
F5 and after F5 Bishop D3 bleeded out as
well more or less by Daniel and Rook a
and here here we
[Music]
are wow uh remarkable
uh and it's interesting that both
players had been blitzing blitzing
blitzing and
stopped like like suddenly cold like
there was a red light suddenly uh in in
in in the position as uh their prep uh
was a exhausted Peter maybe but Danielle
played Queen C2 relatively fast I mean
usually okay the preparation end
somewhere because you just as we already
discussed cannot analyze every position
uh forever and that's also the modern
way of playing that you always come up
with some surprise and you are playing
many many different systems in order not
to let your opponent make a targeted
preparation because if your opponent is
sure that he will get a certain line on
the board and and he checks that line
already couple of weeks in advance and
repeats right before the game then it's
very unpleasant to face such scenario
and this is one of the modern ways of
fighting against that you are ready to
switch systems and you keep your
opponent always in the dark that he
should never really know what to expect
for that exact crucial game which is G
gonna happen right and this move Queen
C2 I really have to question that move
uh Peter because in my mind mind
whenever I was playing these systems as
white and my opponent often times played
uh
F5 I really never wanted to allow my
opponent the opportunity to play E5 E4
and here it's sort of like Donal is just
welcoming black to kind of seize more
space in the center and this bishop on
D3 you know that was supposed to be on
G2 well it's on D3 uh I would have
captured Ed on E5 and I would have
captured on E5 kind of automatic am I
missing a tactic uh because otherwise
you know takes on E5 Rook takes E5 it
looks kind of funny this black Rook
sitting on the E5 Square
would what what what what's going on
yeah well what's going on that hiar
played your move e54 he didn't have to
think twice and uh I mean I'm actually
fascinated and I think it's very nice
possibility for the audience as well to
to see that what a class you have yes
and in your Prime when you were young
full of energy and everything what you
were capable of because every time
whenever we have a strategical position
when it's about maneuvering
understanding structures uh plans and so
on
uxl uh so I mean okay I know you very
well we played our first game I think in
1994 I was 15 years old and and I
believe that actually the game was even
not doing any justice to us because it
was in the Olympiad and for some reason
both United States and Hungary was
struggling at that point and we played
in some basement you remember with some
terrible lights and with some strange
pieces and we had a big theoretical
clash in the
grimfeld SE evalation and it ended in a
draw and we had a very nice postm time
analysis and I still remember it because
it was such a pleasure to to have
analyzed that game with you well uh
thank you very much for the compliment
really uh Peter it's uh it is strange
sometimes to to you know I wonder uh do
I have an understanding and I'm seeing
the move E4 being played quickly by
Hikaru and I feel a little bit better
about what I I know and I just wanted to
remind everybody in the audience that uh
today especially uh yesterday we didn't
have that but today especially we do
have uh Anna Rudolph's chessable course
uh at quite a discount half of your
purchase money goes to support Kea and
it's a macro business lending as well as
we have a premium uh chess 24
memberships where once again half of
your money or membership money goes to
Kaa and you can see on our ke
bar how much money we are raising and uh
our goals that we' set by the way I
wanted again I I think yesterday somehow
when we were closing shop uh Peter I
didn't really get a chance to uh
compliment you and sopia for your
generous contribution as you as you uh
uh donated a thousand Euros to uh to
support Kea and uh thank you for that
most especially and well you can join uh
Peter and also Magnus Carlson is
donating 10% of his prize money to Kea
as well so impact chess and let us know
how uh the uh pandemic and how chess has
impacted your lives
um Peter pick us up uh we've just seen
the move Knight G5
by Magnus what's happening yeah I felt
like there was way too much strategical
fness in the other game and also the
game between dingler and Magnus Carson
started earlier I felt like maybe here
will be more drama developing soon I
mean sooner compared to the other game
and yeah we see some very wild uh
situation here because the position is
very Dynamic but I mean one cannot say
Magnus feeling so comfortable because
look at the clock situation is done to
four minutes so it feels like he relies
on his Instinct that he believes in the
position on the other hand he's not
exactly sure how to how to make it right
move per move and dingly then shows some
confidence because he has eight and a
half minutes he had been playing much
faster than than Magnus yeah and again
this uh doubled Apon me look like oh
this stupid double a pawn but not only
is it irritating uh White has that half
openen bile which means that he also has
his play you mentioned a long time ago
Peter that whenever white will maneuver
his Knight to D5 he's going to put
intense pressure against the pawn on C7
and this kind of it feels to me like a
bridge burning if black doesn't how do
you say break through or land a big blow
on the king side well uh White's Rook B1
and Knight C7 a rook B1 and I don't know
even a potential A5 A6 uh the position
could be very bad for the world champion
yeah absolutely I mean first of all this
Rook on B2 as you mentioned I mean it
has a very nice purpose on putting
pressure on B7 at the same time it also
protects the B2 I mean the F2 Pawn right
uh so it feels like black is not really
in time to to come up with some
energetic attacking ideas and in this
respect I very much like magnus's last
move which was now Bishop A7 to D4 a
move which is quite surprising given the
fact that it seems like the bishop on A7
was a key factor in order to put the
pressure on the F2 pawn and create the
initiative and the bishop on CC was not
doing that much but in fact this bishop
on CC had a very nice purpose because it
guarded the D4 square and it also
protected the A5 pawn and after now
Magnus making sure that this bishop will
be changed he gets access with for his
Knight the lovely D4 square and let's
not forget that with this buttery Queen
G5 and Queen on uh Rook on G6 Queen on
G5 black is eyeing the G2 pawn and if a
knight lands on D4 that's exactly what
black needs in order to distract white
screen from a very nice Square on
F3 yeah beautifully uh explained Peter
right on the point which I I and I
didn't really get a a chance to double
guess the move Queen D1 to F3 because
one of the things that was going through
my mind again is the way I was setting
it up like if black doesn't land on the
king's side white is there on the
Queen's side uh instead of the move
Queen F3 was Queen G4 in inviting black
to win a pawn would that have uh was it
possible yeah it it could have been
possible but maybe I mean I'm pretty
sure that Magnus would not even consider
taking because because no no if Yas
wants end game don't go for it guys just
just believe me trust me if yasel offers
exchange of Queen just keep your queen
somehow Queen makes perfect sense yeah I
kick your queen and probably I will
anyway insist on magnus's idea with
Bishop D4 fair enough okay yeah because
U I think the move Bishop d for was you
know somehow in typical Magnus Carlson
style directly on on time you know just
just in the nick of time to get the
counter play so you can play Knight D4
or Knight takes
A5 yeah absolutely and look at this
Magnus has a choice yeah because it it's
nice to jump in with Knight D4 but at
the same time he also has the chance to
to capture the A5 Pawn because after
Rook B5 you have the move Rook A8
right boldly pointing out the obvious B6
would be a beastly egregious error
oops Yeah and uh you lose a piece so uh
but Knight A5 Rook B5 Rook A8 as you
were showing Peter uh black is just fine
in that in that
scenario yeah but even this maybe is
very sharp because maybe ding wants
Knight d five now and after C6 Rook
takes B7 but no it doesn't work yeah
because Knight B7 Rook B7 you can take
since Queen F7 check is leading nowhere
with this with this pieces protecting G7
yeah right right nice nice and Knight
takes A5 played yes Knight takes A5
played that that A5 Pawn was very
irritating and Knight D4 while it looks
impressive that you've got this battery
Queen G4 or even Queen G3 and you know
suddenly you're facing the music on the
queen side and it's not it's not fun
anymore for
black yeah exactly because here we see a
big difference between the dark s
Bishops being exchanged that now after
Queen G5 I can play the move
G3 and you you cannot really hit me so
easy even though this H5 position is
still very very messy I I don't know
what to what to think about it but ah of
course white goes first to H5 of course
that's the professional move inviting
Rook G5 and once you play Rook G5 I can
come back to D1 and you are missing the
queen G5 option and once again sorry to
be so repetitive that move Rook G5 was
exactly the kind of irritating move that
Coy would play against me then he would
draw his withdraw his Queen to D1 and
then I would be really
angry that he learned me to occupying
the G5 Square Queen H5 very professional
move very nice peter yeah yeah because
uh I think it was also tempting for
Magnus maybe to try to make Knight D4
work but he understood that uh okay he
has to be reasonable and really one has
the feeling that after the dark Bishop
were exchanged the attack is not anymore
in the spirit it's much more in the
spirit if you can recapture this pawn
and then claim that you have you see I
have played a masterpiece because with
A5 first I went Knight E7 then I played
A5 you took that pawn then I maneuvered
to the queen side then I maneuvered for
the for the attack you defended it and
in fact I was I knew that at the end of
the day I will have a nice little move
like Bishop D4 and this Pawn on A5 will
tell yeah exactly it feels like a real
masterpiece so far from Magnus I don't
know who is better or why but it it does
feel very nice well it's intriguing for
me that at the very end of the day after
all of these high class futin strategic
Maneuvers we're talking about Pond
structure and black has a a nicer Pawn
structure after all of these Maneuvers
and he now he goes back and he's ready
for Rook A8 uh can we just take a look
at the other uh semi-final Peter yes
because okay this game was like a
firework but now it little bit settled
done KN it's the good option so this is
the current position Bishop takes
A5 if you could take us to the moment
where E5 E4 was played yeah that was
when we left how did uh things unfold
thereafter yeah E4 was play there was
this one question from you about D Tak
C5 and I was also wondering about this
because if black has to take with the
Rook then it feels loose but however I
think that probably there is a move
Queen D7 which forces the exchange of
the Queens using the fact that you have
no way of protecting the D3 Pawn I mean
DC bishop and then I will collect on E5
already in an end game when it makes
much much more
sense okay in
intriguing yes so Queen C2 had been
played E4 Bishop E2 Knight D5
stabilizing move I mean one has the
feeling impression that black has
Consolidated and it's solid but uh I
mean the structure is still very very
tricky because Bishop D2 Rook A7 A5
white has this very nice Pawn on A5
putting pressure on the B7 C7 pawns and
white is always ready to exchange the
this beautiful powerful stabilizing
monster on D5 with Bishop C4 so that's
the justification behind White's
play so we see that all this is
happening
ahuh so white deine repetition yeah
Bishop d8 targeting the A5 pawn and
white gives up the A5 Pawn but goes
after the B7 pawn and now we are again
back to the pawn structure lot of
finesses but again the pawn structure
white has somewhat better Pawn structure
but black seems to be active enough to
to compensate for it exactly uh my
impression as well is we're getting into
to a major piece ending uh I can I can
make an argument that the pawn on
C6 might be uh a little bit weak uh is
it is it true Peter and is it it's one
weakness all that Danel needs to win
this
game yeah there is there is one weakness
but exactly only one and of course if if
white gets nice coordination it's uh it
can be really unpleasant but also Hikaru
is taking his time and I wonder whether
uh the more natural move would be Rook D
takes A5 but there is also good argument
that maybe he wants something like Rook
a takes A5 and after Rook takes B7
something like Rook B5 fighting for the
B file is that an idea absolutely
um just uh I'm I'm still trying to
understand how we or not is the C6 Pawn
you mentioned some time ago really Peter
you you you have a great uh um foresight
go ahead that that exact variation that
you were showing a moment ago I can also
I can also get this POS I mean I don't
know where we can highlight better the
the weakness on C6 because everywhere
black has some Dynamics yeah yeah
exactly that's why Hikaru is taking his
time right and if in this position the
idea that I was meant to show that if
Rook B5
I would go uh Rook
C7 and uh this idea that also along yes
precisely that was the move I wanted you
to play that uh precisely along the
seventh rank there's a lot of weaknesses
so that I have the move Rook takes
B5 and very nice and this is seizing the
initiative thanks whoops to the back
rank mate but if you took the Rook I
would go check back and check again with
the queen and suddenly it's
white uh that is really uh well I want
to say pressing uh maybe winning uh
exactly Peter a move like that one
threatening to win the queen and a
moment ago you were saying if you can
double along the seventh rank uh White
would uh be uh doing very well exactly I
mean uh the point is that it seems like
black Advance his pawns but those pawns
make black king vulnerable I mean with
the pawn on F7 and the black Pawn on H5
it would be much more harmonious for
black but this Pawn on F5 somehow makes
black king little bit Loose by no means
anything of this was forced as I said
somehow I feel like Rook D takes A5 is
much more natural Okay the reason why
Rook a takes A5 and this Rook B5 idea
clossed my mind that all was just
because Hikaru was taking his time
exactly by the way uh I mean obviously
it's still early in the Set uh today but
total different energy in the games
yesterday it seemed like you know a
ravenous chaotic uh slugfest and today
it just feels like the bo all the
players are a little bit tighter they're
playing more
strategic uh more positional uh
quieter uh maybe they burned themselves
out yesterday was just uh quite a fire
brand uh of of Chess uh Peter yeah but I
also mentioned it while we were
discussing with Tanya at the end of the
day all these developments in the in the
matches and I already highlighted that I
know from my own experience that once
you start losing then there is a
completely different uh chemistry inside
you that you feel like you have to
bounce back at all cost if you are not
losing then you don't have this feeling
you just think that okay let me play My
chess and I will play according to
position but once you lose then you
don't have the desire that I you want to
play according to position you want to
create something from your emotions as
well yeah you want to impose immediately
your will on your opponent at all cost
and I think this somehow was also
reflecting in in yesterday's game
while today so far between Hikaru and
Daniel du things are under control so
there is no reason to get completely out
of your comfort zone yeah that's that's
another way of thinking but maybe before
getting more deep here Magnus has
actually won a game and I I did not know
that Ding will soon design I wanted
anyway to jump there and say that Magnus
has played an incredible Masterpiece
because it looked like like even before
resignation already wow okay our
apologies to our audience as we just let
this completely slip by us oh my
goodness Peter uh we left it literally
about here what has happened to uh ding
Len yeah what has happened that his por
structure is damaged that's what that's
what you also mentioned yeah that all
these finesses and finally it comes down
to pawn structure and this Knight C6 was
the incredible finesse because black
actually sacrifices any of these pawns
on B7 or on C7 but make sure that with
Knight D4 Dynamics he creates so much
pressure that white is simply not let's
just take a look Rook takes B7 black can
take take go Knight D4 and now the big
difference is that whenever you play
Queen G4 then black has the intermediate
check Queen C1 check and you lose the
queen so basically after Knight C6 White
had to go on the defensive with Knight
E3 and if you have to go on the
defensive with this damage Pawn
structure it already means that
something went hard be wrong and if
things go wrong against the world
champion Magnus Carson and they tend to
go wrong strategically wise then you are
about to witness a masterpiece and
Magnus just with steady moves B6 Knight
F5 Rook A8 getting out of this pin
targeting the A4 pawn and the weaknesses
from White's position are never running
away and then it comes also this uh
lecture in your mind that in the
childhood we are taught that be careful
with your pawn moves because pawns don't
move back backwards and exactly imagine
a white Pawn being not on C4 but on C3
it would already give so much more
Harmony to his position but like this it
just
ruins
right so a ding purposely sacrificed a
pawn but what on on some compensation
but Magnus had foreseen that he can
sacrifice The
Exchange Total
Domination and it looks like a Harvest
on the C4 Pawn the E4 Pawn potentially
even King H5 I mean it's it's almost
Overkill how many pawns black can
collect yeah actually I'm little bit
Yeah angry that we don't know the clock
situation if if the resignation was
premature or it was based on the clock
situation in any case White's position
looks terribly
wrong aha we are getting the
confirmation one and a half minute each
more or less so basically time was not a
decisive Factor it probably ding just
felt like enough is enough I mean I just
got outplayed and one thing I really
like in ding that he he likes quality so
I really believe that when he that he
got outplayed and he has zero chances
then he he knows then okay that's it and
he also makes tribute for for Magnus
because okay it was just a wonderful
game from him yeah true that uh however
you know I just kind of have this
feeling that today's players especially
the bullet players and the blitz players
uh they have a
philosophy uh never
resign win on the clock if you have to
but never ever ever
resign uh uh it reminds me of a line by
bent lson when he was uh referring to a
specific player uh he said uh he loses
correctly uh and that the player resigns
when he's supposed
to that he was a very correct
person this is actually a very nice
opponent no yes exactly I mean good he
good understanding you know yeah that's
exactly what we want to face not those
opponents
yeah good understanding but I mean okay
here yeah this this was just enough is
enough because okay black can collect on
e4 black can also rely on his C Pawn
connected with Knight D3 and then push
uh I mean it's White's position is a
total collapse and zero practical
chances and believe me if there would be
no increment definitely would feel like
okay I have to play till the end but
with increment and probably also in mind
that I have just witnessed the total
collapse of myself it's it's very
understandable that he felt like okay
enough is enough now fair enough very
good uh those games will start in a few
minutes uh it looks like
Dan uh as a very nice uh major piece
ending there are some weaknesses and the
six Pawn obviously the F5 Pawn after
moves like Rook C5 uh uh tickling the F
F5 Pawn can be uh on White's agenda not
a pleasant uh defense I would say not at
all yeah not at all and immediately all
these early 90s come to my mind when I I
as a young Prodigy got the chance to to
face the world's best players and of
course I benefited incredibly lot from
all these encounters and I remember and
recall that basically one of the
nightmares scenarios was if I would be
ever forced into such a defensive
position against one of the classical
Masters and uh I mean I made I tried to
make sure never to end up in such a
position where my older Grandmasters
would give me a masterpiece because here
I would have I would have no chance I
believe in a classical game against any
of you right the yeah yeah you don't
want the lesson here here I as white I
really start to be attracted to the move
H for H5 especially for white because it
means that in the future I have G3 G4
ideas but I also have Queen E2 E4 idea
Queen E2 to C2 uh Peter the idea is if
you would allow me to play the move H5 I
don't know who's on move yeah but C5 was
the last move and he could immediately
use the chance and played H5 himself oh
I didn't get the chance to show uh the
tactic that I wanted which was it was
something where I wanted to play H5
Queen C2 I wanted you to take the pawn
on H5 yes perfectly but thank you so
much yes and I would exactly take the
pawn on e4 and this my goodness this is
an ending where yes exactly the the weak
Pawn on E the week e Pond and proy or
not Peter you you were right to avoid
such lessons uh very very nice and that
was why Hikaru got in H6 H5 immediately
how do you rate is this a
5050 yeah well after H5 Queen C2 had
been played Queen G6 King H2 and Hikaru
played Queen G4 so basically is ready to
give up have the C6 Pawn in order to
create counter chances but how does this
line goes
exactly I mean if I take on C6 take take
and queen E2 or queen E2 yeah this is
very nice yeah Queen E2 to to to attack
the pawn yeah and and that's a very
important check that Queen D1 check so
yeah King yeah that would be
a terrible mistake there and again a big
shout out to our audience thank you so
much for joining us for the Magnus
Carlson tour finals we are in the
semifinals uh day two of the semifinals
$300,000 in prizes to be divvied up by
uh our four contestants um during this
finals uh we we are benefiting Kaa so
the bar that you see there on your
screens our goal of
raising uh you can see how we're doing
and uh yesterday uh my colleague Peter
Leo was so generous to donate a thousand
Euros to our challenge of uh giving back
to the community uh because so many are
suffering from the pandemic and also uh
50% dis uh
50% of your membership fees to join uh
chess 24 as a premium member we'll also
go to Kaa as will uh your chessable
purchase of Anna Rudolph's uh course 50%
of your purchase price will also go to
Kea so that now is the time if you ever
wanted to join and become a premier
uh member uh for chess 24 do so today
and we thank you for your support very
very much and uh thank you of course for
joining us uh let your friends know
where you're hanging out and any
questions that you might have for any of
our guests any of our competitors uh by
all means use our uh social media to uh
send your questions to Tanya so that she
could ask them of our players and we've
seen Peter that uh the black Hikaru is
goddess Queen to this very nice F3
square and uh Danel has basically said
uh I'm not interested in winning the C6
Pawn exactly I mean Daniel is also very
clever and we see some incredible fight
between two very creative players yeah I
mean the way Hikaru managed to get K the
play out of this passive position with
this H5 Queen G6 Queen G4 at the the
same time uh Daniel goes for this rookie
eight rookie a rook A5 Rook A8 idea
basically he wants to create himself the
chance of hitting the black king with
some Queen A2 Queen G8 uh check mating
or at least a check but maybe even more
than that and look at this how hiu
reacts you know you are playing nicely
my friend let me also show some
brilliancy look B B6 to B3
played oh
exactly anticipating the the queen
coming to A2 he says take my Rook if you
would like I've got a Perpetual check
nice peter that's a nice move that's
just a very nice move it's a brilliant
move yeah it's a brilliant move I mean
there is no way to escape the Perpetual
right so basically white cannot take on
Beast if he he's playing for a win but
uh also I wonder what what's Black's
next
movies
uhuh uh you know it's strange but
exactly at this moment when I see the
queen landing on F3 The Rook landing on
B3 I start getting a little nervous I
started saying you know I don't want to
see F5 F4 and my name is going to be
immortalized on the wrong side of a
brillian
se you know so I getting a little
nervous uh feeling for Danel like what
is my Rook doing on A8 yeah now he
immediately came back to A1 and now
already The Rook is lose on B3 so Hikaru
bleeds back Rook B6 and King G1 was
played okay so this is how Danielle is
trying to take control of the game but
there was one thing I wanted to to ask
you because after Rook B3 suddenly the
move Rook f8 appeared in my mind exactly
with idea to stop this F5 F4 and I was
wondering that what's your next move
because uh okay I'm not setting Luke
takes F5 yet that's that's a real pity
but maybe maybe it's also not so easy
from the black side to make some move
exactly uh that looks
uh seriously that looks like a great
challenge um especially as you really
have sto my F5 F4 I could play C5 Rook C
Rook C3 Rook C3 is funny because you
will of course go Queen A2 and on a good
day I would play Rook A3 forgetting
about Rook G8 Queen G8 made or something
Rook C1 okay yeah I mean you remember I
was telling you that this cring G8 looks
deadly but is it really deadly because
okay you can go to H6 it would be
terrible to go to G6 because then of
course I have Queen F7 check and it's
checkm but after King H6 let's say queen
h8 king G6 I don't see the followup that
is true and in fact I might have to uh
use some brilliancy to try to make
Perpetual check which might even not
exist so in any case enough reason not
to look into this direction and Daniels
Rook A1 is of course a very sensible
professional move let's get some
stability B6 back King G1 Queen G4
blitzed out by Hikaru and Danielle is
done to 30 seconds 30 seconds oh my
goodness
that
is uh
oh now now you start to Fe when do you
feel the ticking pressure of the clock
uh Peter is it five minutes is it three
minutes is it one minute 30 seconds yes
you're definitely feeling it but when
really start to get nervous I think in
my case one of the big problems since
I'm not having enough practice uh and
working as a coach and not really
playing that much lately it's it's that
whenever the clock ticks done I get
really nervous and my brain's actually
just stop working and that's also one of
the things I I faced in this Legends
tournament that I was playing good I was
playing good quality chest showing my
class everything and then the Clock Was
ticking down and that's it finished you
know whatever happened before how nicely
precisely you played didn't really
matter because some collapse some
terrible blunder would come any second
and uh yeah this this was very tough I
think this is the modern players and all
these players who are very active and
playing tournaments after tournament
they are playing lot of Blitz also
online they play all kinds of events
super tournaments they train all the
time for themselves they are very very
sharp and probably with 30 seconds on
the clock when you have inclement they
are not panicking yet not definitely not
but for myself I know that it was it was
quite a challenge meanwhile we are
having some big fight here going on but
also let's not forget that Magnus cars
and dingl land third game has just
started and dingan is in a must-win
situation because he's trailing 02 yeah
he points he is two points behind so he
has to win on Demand with black to stay
alive against Magnus Carson exactly and
again just to mention that anybody who
may be joining us late first of all
shame on you second of all they are
playing the best of four so it's the
first play who scores two and a half
points out of the four games of course
if you score three well done it doesn't
matter it just means that you're the
winner of the set you're the winner of
today Magnus has started two Z but he
lost the first set yesterday thanks to a
victory in the Armageddon game by ding
Lin so if Magnus was to win the set
today the match would be tied one to one
it doesn't matter whether you won three
zero or you want it in an Armageddon
you're the winner of the Set uh as Peter
just said uh unfortunately for ding Lin
having lost two games he has to win on
demand and Peter we have a Kings Indian
yeah exactly I think that since the
other game is facing time trouble we
will be focusing on that game but I just
wanted to highlight that yes the game
has started and the question was how
will dingl and try to play for a win
with the black pieces against Magnus
Carson well we got the answer he plays
the Kings Indian which he haven't really
been playing lately in the last three
four years he changed his repertoire
completely I think that was also one of
the reasons why he became a 2800 plus
player but let's not forget that in all
the all his childhood and on the road to
becoming one of the very best players in
the world he like
2750 ding mea with the black was the
Kings Indian so he's a natural Kings
Indian player and he goes for it against
against
Magnus very good I it almost sounded
there like you were saying that uh ding
unnecessarily handicapped himself by
playing the Kings Indian defense and the
moment he stopped he became a
2800 pretty impressive I have to share a
story I don't know if you know it uh
Peter but it's absolutely brilliant uh
here in Holland they had a very great
talent his name was yurun pette of
course pette was supported by the uh the
Royal Dutch Chess Federation and they
thought how could we help our Junior we
will send him to Victor kchoi to get
intense training and during these
intense training sessions Victor
convinced Yun pette that the king's
Indian defense was a bad opening and
pette loved the Kings Indian he loved to
play the Kings Indian and this came as
is quite a blow and so in fact such a
blow you you Yun ended up stopping
playing
chess because I mean if you can't play
the Kings Indian and enjoy yourself I
mean chess was just not so much fun
anymore for
again they kind of boomeranged is what I
want to say this this training did
didn't go exactly the way the Dutch
Chess Federation has planned it uh it
seems as if Magnus is aware that all he
needs to do Peter is draw the games draw
the game as he was very fast to trade
Queens yeah exactly I mean he just chose
the most reliable most solid setup and
in fact a setup which is anyway a little
bit annoying for black because it puts
lot of pressure you uh White is very
solid and why just say I I don't mind in
the wor case scenar you equalize and you
make a l and so what and po ding is
faced with this situation that he needs
to win but actually his his possession
doesn't give him any real uh rights to
to play for a win he should be thinking
about how to equalize exactly and with
this move C4 C5 white is of course is
threatening to play Bishop takes A6 he
also opens up the C4 Square for a
maneuver that's very common in the kings
of theit on F3 to D2 to
C4 uh is that's our pillow our Dream
position yeah absolutely and also just
one remark that why this C4 C5 was so
important and so timely because one
could argue that black is kind of stting
with a move like Knight G4 targeting
this wonderful Bishop on E3 but if white
makes sure that this never happens with
HC then black gets exactly this one
little Tempo that he needs with Bishop
f8 taking care of the C5 square and if
White NOW continues with A3 he would
again need only one move to play B4 but
then black continues with Knight C5
putting a pressure on the E4 pawn and
next already going A7 A5 stabilizing the
position and black has all the reasons
to be happy this was the dream scenario
for for ding but Magnus of course will
never ever give this chance played C5
forced ding to to play Bishop f8 Bishop
takes A6 B A6 and N move H3 now Magnus
wants to make sure that he he keeps his
wonderful Bishop on E3 and also stops
sing Bishop G4 ideas again uh ding Len's
play is very very risky allowing Bishop
takes A6 uh but he's not exactly playing
the position unfortunately he's playing
the position in the match and the match
dictates that he has to win on man with
black and that's why he's taking the
great risks he has in a different
situation I don't think he would have
allowed uh Bishop takes A6 and we have
Rook B8 uh and there you see it on our
graphic Magnus Carlson trailing in the
match looks to equalize this best of
five
semi-finals yeah and just a quick update
because finally we never got a chance to
jump back on Daniel duol Hikaru Nakamura
game it ended in a draw there was no
real dramas because by creating this
Contra chance and constantly putting
Danielle uh some headache with all this
meting or Perpetual check ideas finally
Daniel had enough he exchanged the Rooks
and black was just way too active in
this queen end game I mean okay it looks
like white is improving but the problem
is that you have to bring your king
closer and whenever you bring bring the
king closer then black starts some
Contra checks and it ended with a
repetition Perpetual check so there was
nothing to play for so draw there it's a
it's a tie I think it's one-1 one one
has the feeling that in the first game
Hikaru had a chance and in the second
one Daniel had a chance but one has to
give credit for the opponents for the
defensive sides because they both put
off a hell of a defense absolutely and
that is one of the uh I think key
differences I I see you know in a kind
of a chassic terms but not just in chess
but in life that the generations more
knowledge each each generation you know
passes on more knowledge to the Next
Generation so that the next generation
is actually a better group of top
players but one of the things that I
really see is visible difference between
let's say uh my generation today's
generation is there
extraordinarily good defense ensive
games in my uh games often times I could
win a game uh with a very thematic idea
and today those today's players are so
aware of the where those dangers are
they're avoiding them and the defensive
play is just spectacularly good and
sometimes I have this impression that
you can't win a chess game anymore
against these guys and then we have
something like yesterday
which is just you know lightning
striking because we had like eight
decisive games if not more it was just
an it was a slugfest it was
brutal absolutely I mean it's uh it's
really this modern generation because uh
one of the problem sighting modern
generation is facing uh by respect
because the older generation was very
very much respected yeah because there
were no engines so people would look at
the games and would say wow what a what
Masters they are and now the new
generation is faced with the situation
that doesn't matter how good you are
playing the engine right at home will
tell you that I even so you played the
Fantastic game somewhere you could have
played even better and this gives the
the impression from someone who is just
looking the games with the engine that
ah these today's players are playing
very randomly no no that's exactly and
that's why I really love to be a
commentator and that's why I'm also
trying to highlight all these moments
very very much because I know exactly
how difficult it is to be a top player
in this modern era with all these
computers and everything so much
pressure on the players all this move
pan move everything they understand
everything strategically but how to make
them work move pan move and the
opponents are posing so much trouble so
really all appreciation of of the
players because they are doing
incredible job and uh that's why I
always say that wow this is fantastic
and that is fantastic because I just
hate when people are sitting at home and
criticizing the players that they could
have played better yeah exactly I
remember I was laughing uh uh Peter
having a lot of fun with Sylvio Sylvia
Denoff and
Sylvia as the manager uh vesselin topof
had made some very sharp remarks about
Vladimir
kramnick and uh they had played their
world championship match into an
overtime where Vladimir played
incredibly well in one rapid chess game
I mean has the accuracies of his moves
were just fantastic and Sylvio said
there was some some computer cheating
and and I laughed and I I said Sylvio I
want to show you a game it was played by
Paul
Carz in a Soviet
Championship Paul KZ is W in 30 two
moves and every single move of Paul Carz
was the engine's first
choice would you like to say that Paul
Carz in the
1950s you know was a time traveler and
he had access to chess engines Sylvio
was not impressed he didn't like my
explanation but he laughed anyway I mean
he was clever enough to laugh uh Magnus
has sacrificed a C5 Pawn uh Peter what's
happening yeah he has sacrificed because
it seemed like ding is I mean the
position looked very bad but maybe it
was a very move p movish position the
last move Rook B8 creates threat on the
B file and white simply locks one little
Tempo to to fully stabilize so beastly
had been played Knight D7 hits the pawn
on C5 immediately and if you want to
keep that pawn you have to play a move
like Knight A4 Knight A4 gives up some
Harmony and this is exactly what magnos
hates the most he likes Harmony very
much and it also feels like black gets
maybe way too much cont play with let's
say Rook B4 targeting the E4 Pawn you
are forced to play Knight D2 if you want
to keep that pawn yeah you go Knight D2
and black suddenly goes F5 and black
spicy stinks up right and this is not
exactly the the scenario Magnus wanted
the game to to go most probably and said
that you know what I actually don't care
about this pwn because if I stabilize
and I bring my pieces to the right
squares and we exchange some piece then
uh in fact draw suits me perfectly fine
let me just play Simple and he goes He
activated his Knight went all the way to
A5 targeting the C6 Pawn some moves like
Rook ac1 or Rook D6 are hanging in the
air it seems like white is in total
control to to make a draw at least
comfortably
and uh again you use a very nice term
Harmony I mean uh at the cost of a pawn
and again I really do discount the the
pawn loss due to this really fractured
queenside structure that black has but
you can see that the harmony exist uh as
you point out why don't you go Rook D6
with or without Rook C1 uh White is the
one um pushing or sees the initiative I
wanted to ask you Peter I don't think
I've ever gotten a chance to ask you
this
question who was your favorite world
champion the reason I ask the question
is because for me vasel smof was one of
the most underrated world champions ever
and he was a player whose games really
had great
Harmony yeah absolutely I I I perfectly
agree with uh with vasil mlo because Som
he never really played so many
spectacular games so he never got
appreciated so much by the general
public but I if I think about smithl
immediately this queen D4 to H4 this end
game with G takes H4 structure comes to
mind and okay his games had so much
Clarity I of course enjoyed a lot lot of
smithl but my favorite world champion
was tan Petrosian and I think it's also
connected with the fact that uh there
was a book and it was translated to
Hungarian it was like the lectures of
tigan Petrosian and it was my favorite
book it was a book I read like maybe 100
times would be an exaggeration but more
than 20 times for sure and each single
word that was written in that book was
music to my ears it was just like so
beautifully written and after that also
seeing many games from him I just I also
simply fell in love with his chess wow
fantastic because another very very
underrated world champion and uh I
teased a little bit earlier with the
audience and said that we both like
exchange sacrifices so now I know where
where your love for the exchange
sacrifice comes from because that's
something uh we both share uh that Tan's
exchange sacrifices were awesome and I
just want to say they inspired me I now
I'm really jealous I'm angry uh I've
never heard of the book The lectures of
T and petosan because I have something
like a TW volume series on tigr and
petroia and I think it's just behind me
uh a two book uh volume that I really
Lov but I didn't realize that I mean
obviously there were a lot of books in
Russian that American audiences didn't
have access to but I didn't realize one
had been translated to Hungarian you
know was very interesting because I also
didn't know the English title but just
recently FID sent me a letter that
please answer some questions and tell me
uh which chess book made the biggest
influence on you in your childhood and I
knew that this book exists but I
couldn't find it what what it called in
English and then I made some research
and it turned out that the name of the
book is the legacy of pigram Petrosian
the Legacy okay now you know what I'm
going to do a
scramble to find how I can get my hands
on a copy of that book sorry Peter
continue please yes so the book is
really really amazing and then it also
turned out that these were lectures
prepared by tigran to uh to the audience
some radio audience yes so it was not
like it was just only for the for the
top professionals or for for real chess
professionals but also for am mats
and to be honest maybe all this feeling
that I like to explain things and I like
to explain why things are happening in
the game uh might come from this
experience from that book because I
experienced it in my childhood and I was
so fascinated with it that it became
natural for me to to comment this way
yeah wonderful wonderful uh tell us what
has happened Magnus Carlson has
sacrificed upon and he didn't he didn't
try to do anything spectacular he simply
is just the broad Rooks to the center
and played the move F2 F3 Peter yeah
exactly I mean I'm little bit surprised
because we talking about all these Rook
D6 ideas but maybe Magnus felt that Rook
D6 will never really bring anything
since black can answer it with Rook B6
and The Rook looks ugly on B6 but
somehow white cannot really attack it
with Knight A4 no with Knight C4 because
the knight from C5 controls the A4
Square the Bishop from E6 controls the
C4 Square
and black will anyway get the king E7
Tempo so all this Rook D6 doesn't really
bring bring anything and Magnus then s
that okay then let me just play
stabilizing move on the other hand okay
white stabilized but black stabilized as
well and black is still a pawn up okay
damage Pawn structure I don't really
believe that this is any real winning
chance for black or that black can even
think about being better but still it it
would make me a little bit nervous from
the white side if I would feel like
things are getting I mean the control is
getting out of my hand well exactly and
the fact that D luren has very nicely
brought his King to E7 remember in the
end game the king is actually a very
powerful piece and on a good day it's
going to take him a while so uh for
forgive me uh Magnus Carlson fans but on
a good day ding Len who has to win with
the black pieces is trying to play the
move Bishop D7 Knight E6 C6 C5 and
Knight D4 and hey he's utilizing his
extra
Pawn yeah absolutely I think now the
question is that and this is what the
position is about can Magnus try to to
hit black before black gets this so for
example if I move my knight somewhere I
don't know if to E2 or to B1 and you
can't really move the Knight and if you
go Rook B5 I might have something like
B3 B4 aha you can't take because your
knight is hanging and if you are moving
the the Knight away then I get some
really unpleasant check with Knight take
C6 so exactly there are some concrete
lines to to calculate before drawing any
conclusions exactly that was why I think
I wanted to get in Bishop D7 before this
but because this opportunity does uh
Exist by the way just to remind
ourselves uh Peter because we did over
Overlook a game as Magnus won game too
uh the game between Danel and uh hikaro
has also began and it's a repeat of
their previous line of the
sikov that yes exactly and uh like I say
these guys are stubborn huh yeah yeah
but it's also logic because you have to
make up your mind before the before the
match day that what you're going to play
today because you you don't have then
the time between the games in 15 minutes
to to to to jump to some different
opening and uh everything is the same
and now Hikaru played the first new move
compared to that first game today with
B2 B3 in that game Bishop C4 happened
but before we get into all these details
let's just jump back to the magum game
because things things escalated exactly
the way we we discussed with Knight E2
Rook B5 B4 being played now black jump
with the Knight to A4 of course yeah
this is the right Square Knight takes CC
check Knight takes C6 check pardon me
and King F6 so here we are that's the I
no A3 played as well A3 and uh I miss oh
there is Knight o Knight A7 is a is is a
very scary Fork uh I was thinking that
Knight B2 might be Black's choice but
Knight A7 is an
issue yeah and also let's not forget the
draw is enough for Magnus yeah precisely
once again Magnus leads this day two
second set two nil uh over ding Len as
uh ding Lin uh won the first set of
games yesterday uh quite spectacularly
and in and an armag again as well
breaking a 19 game mini match streak um
yesterday one of the things I also
wanted to ask you you you touched base
with it with Tanya for a moment and I
really strongly believe that as well is
that in the top tournaments uh the
classical top tournaments I wanted to I
describe it as the tyranny of the ELO
that is to say it's because of the
ratings that the organizers are inviting
the top players they want to have the
highest category event of all time and
blah blah blah so they invite the the
players with the highest ELO ratings and
because of that the players um are very
jealous of their ELO rating
points and they keep an eye on their
elos during the tournament they don't
want to risk their elos too much so the
tyranny of the ELO means that the
players risk are reduced com
uh on the other hand for the Magnus
Carlson tour there's no Fay ELO ratings
to be won or lost so the players can
play more freely your your uh reaction
to that Peter yeah absolutely I I agree
because uh the point is
that the the result in super tournaments
is just way too important because
imagine you have a so-called bad result
you lose 15 points it might mean that
you are out of the next grun chest tour
you are out of this you are out of that
for maybe one year and it's uh it's a
terrible blow for all the players
because first of all it's a very
prestigious tournament on the other hand
on during these tournaments you can
really earn good money and if you earn
good money you can invest more in your
chess development so it's all like a big
circle it's not just about about the
money about the development about the
chance of getting stronger and stronger
so the pressure is too high and another
problem while all the same players are
keeping the highest rating they are of
course fantastic players but they are
playing always against each other and
all these players are very very
professional they are always working and
believe me it's not like the players
want to make the RO just that if you
openon and plays a brilliant game and
he's very well prepared they are one of
the best players in the world it's just
very difficult to win a single game and
then the public often gets annoyed that
ah again the same super tourament with
the same name and another draw and too
many draws and so on it's not done
deliberately it's simply the the system
itself is is too tricky I mean it's it's
it's not easy to deal for the players
and here everybody can play freely
finally everybody understands also that
it's a show it's like a chess spectacle
people wants to see as much fight and as
much blood as as possible and you can
forget about of course everybody fights
for the result it's clear but it's not
that extraordinar important as in any
super tournament exactly and fighting uh
to the last drop uh is definitely what
we saw yesterday uh just I mean I was
kind of I was kind of left a little
breathless to be honest uh the players
have followed a little bit something
that we had uh looked at Peter uh Knight
B2 appeared on the board as did Knight
A7 yeah I mean it seemed like it was
very logical and I just wanted to
highlight one thing yeah that we already
spoke about Harmony and when you look at
this position it's again one I mean once
again it looks so harmonious for white
typical Magnus and we we saw that it
looked like black is about to stabilize
and Magnus was taking its slow but just
another proof how nicely Magnus is able
to to evaluate all these Dynamic factors
that there was no need to rush he just
put everything in a perfect place and
one me move before black would finally
stabilize with Bishop D7 as you
mentioned Magnus was ready to strike
with a force sequence and uh now he's
having everything under control the only
point is that uh I don't know how much
he wants from this game because after
all draw is draw is enough as well but
hango now he played Knight C8 what is
this Knight C8 if you play Knight C4
what is his
point yeah the Knight ah beautiful Rook
takes C4 Bishop C4 Knight D6
wow wow because the The knce Rook C7 has
a
issue
oops tactics uh Peter yeah fantastic
stuff yeah the Watch Dog of strategies
and ding has reacted with Rook B8
now we can bring our somehow we need to
bring talking about Harmony I'm saying
the harmonious Square would be the night
on C5 and I I I see just above your head
there that we had this very nice clip of
Anna Rudolph cyborg Anna there as H her
chess course her chessable course which
will teach you how to attack by the way
um is a on a discount uh today we have a
special that uh half of your purchase
price will go to support our Kea
undertaking as uh the same is true if
you would like to join uh and become a a
premium member here on chess 24 I don't
know Anna looks terrifying with that uh
uh with the red eyes uh she's actually a
sweetheart but uh attack like a machine
is available at a very significant
discount today throughout the entire
event this uh this finals uh the premier
membership uh half will go again to
supporting Kea and we've just seen a mo
I just when I was sure that Rook C6 was
magnus's Choice he played the move Rook
C2 uh why did he do that uh Peter yeah I
was also expecting Rook C6 on the other
hand Rook C2 is a very nice move because
okay he actually only needs a draw and
his Pawn up uh so if he feels that this
move was for some reason even more safe
because after all he after Knight D3
instead of going for Rook C6 now he can
just retreat with his Knight to C4 if
I'm not blundering anything and uh
threaten to to stabilize the position
fully and he's Pawn up so yeah Knight C4
played aha you you even don't need those
adventures with Rook C6 rooke takes A6
maybe the Knight on D6 will be
eventually trapped or you blunder
something this is very safe very nice
you are about to play Knight A5 which
black cannot really allow but this case
Rook C8 allowing Knight E3 is also very
sad yeah exactly I mean it I don't know
what is more frightening Magnus when
he's just in his play playing Zone when
he's just playing incredibly well or
Magnus when all he needs to do is make a
draw he's
like that that that's a very very
difficult assignment you go out and you
beat Magnus when he wants to make a draw
that's tough uh they they had that great
joke you you were obviously since you
were a t and Petrosian fan you you must
have uh learned a lot of those jokes
that they said about PE that Tan t was
so strong uh that uh when he wanted to
make a draw he was often making a draw
from a position of strength that is to
say a lot of his opponents were doing
making moves to avoid a
draw and when the draw offer came they
were
lost so it was like really it was pretty
tough Robert burn once told me about
tigran petosan the guy was so strong he
was making a defensive combination long
before you realized you could
attack reminds me of the super computers
usually that I think one of the ways to
win against a supercomputer is that the
supercomputer realizes that he's in
trouble before you even notice that he
you have any chance yeah and then he
goes he goes crazy you know because he
feels that this is the the Lesser ail
yeah and then suddenly you are given a
winning position yeah yeah exactly in
David Levy came to Seattle Washington my
hometown and there was a chess
computer competition now trust me in
those days of 1976 the computers played
awful so much so that it was great to go
and watch the computers play again sorry
to interrupt yes but magnos just
basically accepted a repetition of moves
so he doesn't he doesn't want to show
that I'm pull up I just want to seal the
match Victory okay and uh we have seen a
repetition of moves all right so uh
Magnus Carlson has won today's set he is
very very likely that he will join us to
discuss today's games and if you have
any questions now is for Magnus now is
the time to get in touch with Tanya as
Magnus ties the match uh winning losing
losing set one but winning set two two
and a half one and a half so
congratulations to Magnus just to
complete the story what happened was the
computers were playing each other in
Seattle in
1976 and one computer sacrificed a rook
blundered a rook essentially blundered a
rook and and he lost the game and it was
pretty pathetic it was like you know
like oh that that computer was really
lousy he he blundered a rook and David
Levy who was the host of the show and he
was just asking the the programmer why
did your program play this B yeah sir
sorry to interrupt but I think we have
both Tanya and Magnus with us so the
story will continue okay it we'll
adjourn it hi Magnus hi Tanya thank you
yes thank you be congratulations Magnus
on today's wi thank you all right so
today 30 look like complete control from
your side um also appeared like you were
on a mission after yesterday as Jonathan
to still put it up grandmas Jonathan on
on Twitter if we can just have that
up and Jonathan well Magnus certainly
turned up large green and angry today
Magnus extra motivation for today's
match um yeah obviously obviously today
was uh was crucial in the sense that I
couldn't really couldn't really for to
lose
um and uh yeah the analysis that I was
upset after yesterday of course was was
quite was quite uh correct but the the
match really didn't get going today um I
think the first
game I I thought he was sort of
equalizing and then suddenly I was
winning so that was a bit weird um but
yeah in general uh I I I I played a good
match today and I think I was in
control we felt that as well while
playing did you as the match progressed
and developed did you get the feeling
like today you were per perhaps more
informed than
ding um yeah I
mean the I I was surprised by his
opening choice so I didn't really I
didn't really know too much more than
that
this sort of position is a little bit
more pleasant for for white but that
that is sort sort of the nature of the
line that every we white is a little bit
better and you just have to to choose
which line to to go for so I don't think
like this came as a particular uh
surprise to him either
um but I I guess at some point it
became um
it became uh a lot more more unpleasant
but
um again I think yeah I had some like
very small idea of how to play here and
I think he was slightly surprised but I
um I don't think it's it was like a big
deal
regardless um Magnus even the opening
approach from your end looked quite
different we didn't see as sniko we
didn't see any London um what was the
idea the concept of changing was it
based on yesterday's
games um I don't know I I just thought
after the first game it made made sense
to just play No Nonsense um solid style
and then of course even in the second
game the first chance I got I got to sa
sacrifice something ium jumped at it so
you cannot keep your instincts uh locked
up for for for long I guess um but yeah
I think that was just uh I I just wanted
to play something more or less common
sense in the in the second game um
because I felt
that I would like if I just play solidly
I would have decent chances of of
winning the game even then because he
has to take risks at some point so um
that that was my thought process there
that's quite interesting what you said
about having an opportunity to sacrifice
and then taking it we felt that there
was a very um pretty different approach
to the entire match today even Ys as
well as what we're seeing with Hikaru
and duab compared to what was going on
yesterday yesterday was just explosive
from the start uh H how would you
explain that do you think just the fact
that today has been just so much more
positional and strategic compared to the
madness that we saw on the board
yesterday um I guess it's good for for
mental health
[Music]
um I think I don't necessarily know if
there's a conscious approach there it
can sometimes be a bit
coincidental and I also want to ask you
that yesterday was after a 19 match
winning streak um the first match that
you lost
uh was it how disappointing was that I'm
sure it was very disappointing but also
what did you take away from that mine
what did you modify coming into today's
game um well my my takeaways were
that um I played really poorly in the in
the first game and then in the
Armageddon game and apart from that it
wasn't wasn't really that bad and then I
mean I I lost one game
by uh
[Music]
basically not registered registering
that my opponent had moved because other
otherwise I think in that first splitz
game like
objectively um the position is fairly
equal but I I felt that I in Practical
terms I had excellent chances to win and
then just to sit there um watch your
time run out is is of course it's of
course
Madness yeah we did have some technical
glitches and just I I mean it'll be
great if you could clarify that for us
even when um dink had gone rookie too in
in the game that you were black
something had happened but that was not
a disconnect could you and apparently
you didn't receive the move could you
exactly tell us what happened at that
moment no so my screen I mean my my zoom
was clearly working so I felt that I was
clearly connected to the internet on my
screen no move happened uh and then he
he ran out ran out of time um but there
was no like
message there was no message like you
won the game which when people
disconnect and run out time they they're
going to show you that you won the game
so his time went to zero and I just
didn't really understand what what was
happening I felt that uh I there could
not be an issue with my connection um
and
um uh yeah right it was definitely very
uh very weird um and it sort of affected
me in the in the first split scam as
well because my first reaction was when
I didn't like register his move and my
time was running for some reason I
immediately sort of thought there could
be some some some issue here and that
just really messed
up um that really messed with my mind
yeah the Perils of online chess and I
think this is something that even ding
has struggled with in the previous event
massively even just the fear or just the
thought that you could disconnect at any
point really plays on you Magus we have
a question from uh from our audience but
before that all right we have that up
first and hand shoed asking would you
like to play for the world championship
using the set system a best of five sets
each set for classical games in case if
a TI rapid and then Blitz isn't this
something that you spoke about I think
it was in 2018 or maybe last year that
um that you do like this set system that
involves all formats for the World
Championship uh yeah I mean I haven't
thought about um that idea
specifically um but I think well why not
it sounds sounds very very interesting
to sounds very interesting to
me okay and because you're here and
we've got this position up with Hikaru
and Daniel could you also just give us
your thoughts before um before I hand it
over to Yas and Peter um about what's
going on in this game um it's the kind
of uh position that always looks a bit
ugly for black but somehow holds up so
I'm kind
of my my guess would be
that uh that black holds here but I
mean that's the that's the thing about
the the snik of that in some lines you
you tend to tend to suffer a
bit and um yeah so he's he's just on
Rook B2
and it's it's it can be a question of
whether you can
equalize immediately otherwise yeah you
might never never equalize at all Magnus
you say that the thing about snov is
that in some positions you tend to
suffer um to us it appears like you tend
to suffer unless it's you who's playing
sniko we've seen it be a difficult line
for others just going back on that world
championship question that we had
earlier about the format
um in the Legends we had karpov and Gary
also discussed the format and they
believe that the classical world
champion should be decided primarily on
classical chess but you have often uh
expressed that rapid and Blitz and all
these different formats and to be the
best in that is what makes you the best
in the world what do you what do you
what's your take on this uh do you think
it should be restricted to classical
player or do you think all formats
should be part of the classical World
Championship I I I mean I've I've spoken
about this before and I think it all
comes down to what you want to achieve
do you want to to see do you want to
have a classical world champion or do
you want to find out who the best player
in the world is and I think the I've
always said that um in order to find out
the best player in the world uh the the
system that we have now is not very good
so I'm I'm sort of fine either either
way but I I think that Gary and and to
is their opinions are also colored by
the fact that they that they played in a
somewhat different time where there were
well first of all there were more games
but also opening theory was not quite as
advanced and Gary did have to play he
had to face the Berlin in in some games
uh and he didn't get anywhere
right uh and that was sort of the the
start of just people banging their heads
against opening they openings they
cannot they cannot crack at all um in in
these matches
and that's one of the reasons why I feel
that there's in the in these matches
there's just two
little um room to prove that you're a
better chess player um so I don't
think restricting the
the restricting it to to classical chess
is is good if you want to find out who
the best player is if you don't if
you're not interested in finding out who
the best player is if you don't just
want to have um a show and continue
tradition then I guess it's
fine yeah that's uh thank you for your
insights on that Magnus and I'm going to
uh bring in Peter and yes to just
perhaps ask you a couple of quick
questions about your game if that's fine
can you stay with us for a little more
all right uh yes about the game uh let
me jump in first first of all uh
congratulations a good day at the office
Magnus I didn't have any uh specific
chess question I'm going to leave that
to Peter I just wanted to say thank you
uh to you personally uh for your
donation to Kaa my understanding is
you're giving 10% of your prize fund I
think the people from ke are hoping
you're going to win the
tournament yeah we we have similar
interests there yeah exactly so thank
you for that and Peter will like
doubtlessly have a chess question or two
for you yeah congratulations Magnus it
was a fantastic performance I don't
really want to ask too many questions we
also have another game running but the
game number two today it it really
looked like a masterpiece from outside I
just would like to ask you if you could
little bit explain what went through
your mind after all this Pawn sacrifice
and combining with King side attack and
then switching back to strategical play
with this bishop D4 from outside it it
was truly impressing us um I mean I
think the reality when you when you look
at with a computer is is always going to
be a bit um it's always going to be a
bit different but yeah this was really a
case of you know um finding a plan
executing the plan and winning the game
so you don't you don't obviously get to
see to see that very often but I think
like uh with with the computer it's it's
not so it's not so clearcut um that this
was all well at the very least as easy
as it looked in in the game but
certainly uh certainly um it was um was
a very U very pleasant game to to play
in the sense that I just managed to uh
to do everything that I I
wanted y sir you have something to add
uh no I I I I actually think that you
hit it right on the the head very well
and uh Magnus again today your play was
really outstanding so we're just going
to say congratulations if you would just
stay with us once a bit and just give us
your your overall you you you mentioned
that you you felt that if black doesn't
equalize right away in the Hikaru uh
position uh he's suffering
um share with us uh your approach your
take on this exact position I think we
just seen the move Bishop F5 by the
way um well my
first my first impression is that Bishop
F5 is a sign that things have gone a
little bit
wrong um it feels like white
is very close to uh to sort of
consolidating and having a better
position there
but it's very very hard to say and also
obviously Daniel is uh is an extremely
good tactician so if there are resources
he will continue not only to look for
them but probably also to
um to find them and and yeah Queen D2 is
definitely the move that I would have
played as well uh at
least
um at least without looking at it um
too uh in in too much detail and it's
really hard to see how black is going to
to fix um to fix these
issues here
[Music]
but uh I wouldn't say anything
for for for sure because I could just be
missing something tactically like who
knows maybe E3 is a good move here right
right E3 F E3 Bishop
E4 that type of a sacrifice
yeah uh we had a Twitter fan who uh who
went so far and boldly said that uh ding
Lin might might be your cryptonite uh
what do you think about that uh comment
Magnus maybe we have lost Magnus I'm not
sure oh
oops hate that
Tanya I yes I I I'm not sure if Magnus
is still with us uh but we will probably
get him back if he is if not
congratulations Magnus and we will see
you tomorrow um but the game is still on
so let's get back to that yes Peter okay
thank you Tanya funny how uh Magnus cut
out just the moment that I mentioned
Kryptonite okay Peter what's going on
Magnus was a little bit CES just not too
sure White's almost got his grippers on
the position yeah I was very happy to
hear this from Magnus because I had very
similar s and was nice to to hear that
he's also a bit confused it's the
position itself is very confusing it's
also very move pa movish uh lot of lot
of tactics in the a now for example the
big question is uh what is really
happening I mean this Rook on D1 is
always hanging but the Rook on D1 makes
sure that the Knight on D5 is nicely
protected at the same time black is
often threatening to take on D5 and take
the pawn on B6 so lot of lot of issues
for both sides to deal with and with
this little time control I mean okay
Hikaru has time Advantage he has already
now spent some time and now played the
move Knight E3 I think this is very
important that he has more time on the
clock than than Daniel because in this
position one has the feeling that the
players will still need to make some
very important decisions and then you
need this extra time exactly now the
move 93 I mean inviting a trade of uh
like light squared Bishops we've
mentioned this before take the two
Bishops away from your opponent is they
if they have them it makes a lot of
sense but on the other hand um Peter I'm
sitting there going why isn't he pushing
his Pawn to B7 why didn't he go B6 B7
push him
baby well probably he couldn't I mean
I'm I'm just guessing but I imagine some
B7 Bishop A5 trick coming your way ah
because you you as you mentioned for the
The Rook on D1 kind of a tactical Target
there in the position uh just to
continue the line I don't I don't mean
to be stubborn yes thank you Queen D4 I
I'm I'm trying to see tactically because
that pawn on B7 is you know H it's such
a it's such
a yeah but now can I I know if I take on
D5 you take with the queen right that's
right because there was this nice trick
nice trick I I saw that one yeah yeah I
mean just to
illustrate I mean really sorry guys
there is sometimes Some Noise probably
in my uh stream because we are fight the
government is fighting against the
mosquitoes you know we have some we have
some terrible fight and and now the
flights are flying exactly over my my
house just to make sure that we will be
safe but I hope that it will soon and uh
yeah it's it's just very complex I don't
know I mean we can easily be missing
some something here I understood but 93
is just a perfectly fine move and by the
way my money is on the
mosquitoes I think they they're going to
win the fight yeah no the point is I
think that according to the European
Union regulations you cannot use any
more this flight system at least that
was the the state but since everything
got completely out of control and
already the people were like okay then
we are collapsing then some new
emergency rule appeared that yes exactly
in this current situation you can use it
uhu so we are fighting back yeah okay
okay so uh Magnus and moment ago was
mentioning that the move tactical moves
like E4 E3 are the kinds of moves that
black is uh has in his pocket he didn't
play it Danel Play Bishop F6 yeah
because I mean the move KNC I like it
from a practical point of view that so
many tactics were hanging in the air and
if you see that with Knight E3 you are
given a chance to stabilize and black
was not able to to utilize on the moment
to to capture the B6 SP due to the
hanging Bishop on E6 I mean even this
had to be done carefully I mean after
Bishop B6 probably white would have just
taken on B6 Rook B6 Bishop E6 making
sure that you get the technical winning
position the other line Bishop takes C6
is actually also working because after
Bishop takes C3 you have the
intermediate move Luke takes B8 but if
you would not have Rook takes B8 then
actually things would be out of control
because F E3 loses to Rook B2 and queen
E3 loses to Queen D1 right just to
illustrate that yeah there are so many
tactics and after Knight E3 Bishop takes
E4 Knight C4 you know that now this will
never work for black and if it never
works then and you get a stable
Advantage who cares if this Advantage is
big or big enough you just know you have
the advantage your opponent has 30
seconds on the clock let's go for it
it's practical nothing can happen to me
and I might win the game exactly huge
huge uh Edge on the clock for
Hikaru in this one to one score two
draws and we're in game three so I don't
know Peter that's uh an awfully awfully
big uh time advantage and uh with all
due respect Hikaru is handling the snov
pretty
well yeah and I'm to be honest very
happy because he is using the system
that 50 years ago uh forced me kind of
to give up the I was not happy that all
these lines were not
so nice for black you always had to
suffer and when you play the sikov you
play for Dynamics you play for for
counter chances and in this line you
were kind of limited to to somehow work
out everything till the draw and uh I
did a lot of lot of work and I think
that this whole line is very very
drawish but you have to know your stuff
and it seems to me like the modern
generation concluded this line is kind
of yeah it used to be the old classical
line but with modern technology this is
drawish and it should be D and they did
not spend enough time or they did not
expect enough this line and I'm very
happy to that today's game by Hikaru
shows that there is still a lot of work
to be done for black to be able to to
make a draw secularly here um
interesting I think that uh thank you
for those
comments uh you you provoked a question
and that is uh we very properly
acknowledge Danel as quite a
theoretician and he's comes up with some
really fascinating ideas so uh congrats
to him all due respect how do you rate
Hikaru as a opening theoretician because
to be frank it looks to me in these
games that Hikaru is is is saying hey I
I know my stuff
too yeah definitely I mean I think that
Hikaru was always one of the players who
knew his stuff quite well it's just that
he was not that precise but I think then
also he changed because he was like a
Kings Indian player he was taking too
much risk but then he also understood
that on the highest level uh Kings indan
is is not really beneficial because it's
a they can Target it and it it makes
your life difficult then he switched to
Queens Gambit then he he it's not only
changing the opening but also changing
your approach to chess Yeah by playing
the king in then he wanted to play free
being able to play the chess he likes to
play but when you play so-called
classical openings you have to go
according to the rules of the position
and if the position requires you to play
to make solid moves then you have to
make those solid moves regardless if you
want them or not and there was kind of
some Clash of style uh between these
whole things but he he went on this way
and he he stabilized and I remember that
in this years like 2015 2016 I think
this were the years when Kar also had
like 2800 plus ratings it showed like he
he really had very good preparation but
then something happened it felt to me
like his goal of becoming world champion
did did not really work out finally and
he might have lost motivation and then
last couple of years I felt like his uh
openings went done due to probably less
work than before and I see the evolution
during the this whole Magnus chess tour
like he started out slowly in the
openings because he did play very well
in the first events but his openings
were by far not that impressive and all
of a sudden now for the finals his
openings look very good again it
indicates for me that he he worked very
seriously and by the way it seems like
he's about to win this third game
against Daniel and what a pivotal third
game it is uh when we left the uh
position uh Peter that the one I have up
I see a knight on C4 if you take us uh
through what has happened since that
Bishop trade took place we saw Bishop F
yes Bishop I think actually this this
moment that we saw with the bishop trade
is the is the crucial moment of the game
because after taking this and getting
rid of any kind of Dynamics now this B6
Pawn is just way too powerful and blacks
count chances which were based on this
Lose Knight powerful but lose Knight on
D5 lose Rook on D1 everything is
perfectly protected there are no
weaknesses and uh black needs way too
much time to generate counter playay but
with this B7 Pawn you just don't have
the time and white can even make moves
like GC because you don't have a knight
to jump on the F3 square and finally
Hikaru just prepar something to C6 or
something to C8 at the right moment and
uh then he have did play a l this six
and let's not forget Danielle is making
all his moves with 10 seconds on the
clock so just in the last second it's
it's total desperation right now so bad
position and no time yeah and uh we just
saw this move Bishop
F4 uh it looks like the Tactical
sequence to my eyes with either Queen C8
check or Knight C6 are going to be uh
lights out uh oh here even saw Queen C7
that looks like a good move too Peter
yeah exactly because I noticed that
after Queen C check Rook dd8 it's for
sure game over but still it continues
and usually in this position you are
really irritated when you feel that the
game still continues and then I spoted
that okay but what if you do exactly the
same with just Queen C7 a softer touch
but where is this Rook going from B8 and
you cannot move the Rook from D6 because
then the bishop on F4 is hanging but
hiar chose go Queen C8 uh okay I'm
pretty yeah he goes for this uh Queen
sacrifice yeah the I was about to say
the queen sacrifice with Rook C8 really
I mean as you say the softer touch but
sometimes the harsh approach is pretty
bad too because after a move like say
queen E8 we're just going to take the
rook and go Knight C6 and uh it's
coronation time yeah you can even
include taking the bishop but you can
include any moment as you wish yeah yeah
Knight C6 that and should hearu win uh
dare I say it Peter Tanya but uh I'm
kind of a
Nostradamus here as I predicted Hikaru
Hikaru won yesterday and it would give
him a big a big boost if he was to win
today interestingly Peter um s interrupt
Danielle resigned after G takes F4 so
yeah Hikaru did win this game but let's
not forget that this is is just game
three so we will have a game four where
Danielle will have the white pieces so
it's the game is still on yeah with a
must-win and I wanted to say that in his
interview and there you see our Graphics
of our current situation game four
coming up between Hikaru and dnell uh he
Magnus basically said he couldn't lose
today I mean it was just like it you
know that would put him on the on the
brink of elimination and he didn't even
want to go there uh I thought that was a
very interesting Insight uh because of
all the people you would think okay if
there's anybody can come back from two
sets down it would be Magnus your take
on on on magnus's
thoughts well it's uh very very
interesting because it's it's obvious
that yeah going zero2 is is very
dangerous but uh we haven't seen this in
the chess board usually I I hate The
Knockout format because I simply felt
like it's not fair and if you look at
the what happened yesterday I think it
was a very nice illustration that yeah
we had some incredible fireworks we had
four players giving their absolutely all
and at the end somebody won and we had
the feeling that any of the players
would have deserved to to to win yeah
because the fight was so 10 and The
Knockout format with best of five this
is something completely different
because at the end of the day you will
okay maybe if the match goes 22 and the
fifth set finally is decided by
alagon chess game then we will have this
s feeling of sorry for the one who who
loses and misses out on qualification
but otherwise if the the match ends
somehow more or less normally then you
don't have this feeling that aha okay
just somebody was knocked out
prematurely yeah I mean the one who won
the match really deserve to win and for
this regard I really love this love this
system and you know I'm one of those
guys who like classical stuff very much
and I believe in Tradition in chest and
so on uh but I do very much understand
especially now seeing all these formats
and what is happening here in the Magnus
chess tour with all these matches and
especially now in the finals with uh not
just best of three but best of five and
then later with best of seven
that uh this is really a very very
interesting format because uh uh maybe
this is exactly what chess is chess is
missing but before I get into it more we
have Tanya here please share us what you
think P absolutely you're right that
this format of a best of five and then
going into the finals with best of seven
is we've seen the Magnus Carlson chestor
have a brutal format and a very
difficult one for everyone to deal with
but I think think this just takes it to
the next level and I do believe that uh
whatever we know about about Magnus and
uh generally his approach to chess he
wants to always make it more challenging
to prove who is truly the best and I
think when you have a longer longer
match play and when you've got more
matches it's uh you know I think that
that quality of stamina the quality of
uh going that extra distance and being
able to be consistent in that is uh what
makes it what makes the best in the
world while all the chess action has
been on we've also heard from all of you
on Twitter and some of that caught our
attention so let's get to that while
Peter and Yas catch a breath before our
final game with Daniel having being in a
must-win situation to take the Match
Into The Blitz portion so we heard from
Big Daddy D and he says nice to see
Magnus playing great today the Beast
inside was awakened indeed I don't think
that Beast Ever sleeps to be honest
we've seen the guy go on to different
platforms and play Blitz and play bullet
chess after having an entire day of
Chess as he himself said he's addicted
um yes yesterday was a tough day but he
bounced back and how wrapped up the
match in three games let's move on to
our next
one sanon writing in with four more days
to go for
grandchester I
I think he means the Magnus Carlson
Chester we're talking about the
grandchester of course none of us can
wait for over theboard chest to return
and the grandchester which had to be
which had to be canceled due to the
pandemic and uh then chess 24's response
to come back with an online version of
somewhat like a grand chest store I
would say uh anyway so he says would
like to thank this initiated by Magnus
and chess 24 for making chess
enthusiasts evenings exciting witnessing
live online tournament looking for for
more such tournaments ahead uh santon
you're absolutely right I think I think
this has been um an extremely difficult
and a challenging time for all of us and
we've spoken about this on the broadcast
and chess has been a fantastic tool with
with an amazing impact on our lives of
uh just bringing in that positivity and
bringing the community together the only
spot that survived it and then we were
treated to this incredible Tour all
summer long it's a little Bittersweet
that we are in the final because uh it
means it's closer to the end but with
chess 24 the action does not stop and
there's a lot more exciting stuff coming
up uh not going to be revealing too much
but I'm sure you'll be able to find all
of that on chess 24 and like I've always
said if you have enjoyed this and you've
enjoyed the broadcast and uh you've
enjoyed the tour definitely consider
going premium to support what chess24
does because that's what keeps it going
and uh like Yas said himself no better
time than now now because it's also a
way to support Kaa we're going to be
talking more about that but let's take a
look at the other tweet that we received
from kanak and he says I would like to
appreciate the commentary by Yas and
Peter I mean Yas is such a polite person
and his laugh is very joyful U kanak you
are on point I um I think I think Yas is
the most polite person that I know I've
I've been fortunate to hang out with him
during our St Louis broadcast and what
you see of him on screen EX exactly how
he is off screen you know what they say
shivalry is dead whoever says that
hasn't met yes yet all right
let's Tanya after that one I I I owe you
a wonderful
dinner that was
great I had no idea that you were still
with us and not on
your I was I was listening it sorry to
interrupt no not at all uh uh but
absolutely um yes you are incredible and
your commentary is just uh is it's such
a pleasure to listen to yes and Peter
both all right let's move on to the next
one and we
had Andrea writing in with it would be
nice to get a final between Magnus and
Daniel at impact chess it would be a
match between the champion and his
second who knows the really deep
thoughts of the number one and those are
I completely um I'm completely with you
in the sense that I get what you're
saying totally I think a match between
these two is always exciting to watch
and Daniel dubov even in U in the
linduras Abby qualifiers beat Magnus
Carlson and he's always been a tough
opponent for Magnus because of his
extraordinary style of play his
combative uh his aggressive energetic
play and I think Magnus also said in in
an interview himself that dubov knows
where he can where Magnus feels
extremely uncom comfortable and this is
also because perhaps they've they've
prepped together they're friends they've
worked on chess together so it would be
interesting but right now for that to
happen Magnus Carlson has to overcome
ding Len's challenge in the semi-finals
he has managed to level the score by
winning the second set but more
importantly Daniel has to not only come
back from yesterday's loss but first
equalize the match today and take it
into the blitz what else we got on
Twitter let's take a look Andrea again
it's a gift to listen to Peter and yes
at impact chess these players think like
humans the engine is a tool for them not
a substitute for the brain and they can
explain the the plan behind the move
thank you and this is the reason why
chess 24 brings these amazing
commentators to all of us because
otherwise to be honest this level of
Chess would go over our heads and uh we
need all the help that we can get from
these great players uh to to break down
the plans to us because it's easy to
kind of see the engine bar going up and
down to get an evaluation but to truly
understand the Beauty and the ideas and
the plans and the breakdowns of the
action that happens over the board we
need uh we need experts and uh to
explain it to us so that we get how
these beautiful minds
work absolutely all right and um and as
we can see and we also heard from
flaming saying hi Tanya you guys are
doing a great commentary job I can see
that 29 donors have donated 29 donors
have donated 293 USD how do I donate and
where will the money be used for what
purpose great question Fleming and thank
you so much for considering contributing
to this cause uh as you can see the bar
that's under me right now which shows
the amount of money that that a chess 24
through premium membership has raised
for K's campaign Kaa is a not for-profit
organization they've been on since 2005
and since then they have been supporting
uh small businesses and entrepreneurs by
lending money at zero interest to help
them set up and to help them Thrive
these are communities which are
underserved and isolated and talented
businesses and K's been doing that
forever and then of course the pandemic
happens and we all know what it's
affected all our lives but it's
especially been these small businesses
and these uh uh underserved communities
that have had the biggest impact and K's
appeal and K's response has been to
raise funds for these and chess 24 is
extremely proud to support this and to
support this uh uh this This brilliant
cause which chess by using chess really
because chess has given us so much
during this uh difficult time so through
chest to also leave a big impact on the
community uh and and all you have to do
is consider going premium by going
premium for yourself and flam flaming
you asked what is the way to do it you
can either buy membership for yourself
or you could you could even gift a
membership you could gift it to to
students to schools to your friends and
whatever money is raised during the
Magnus Carlson Chester benefiting Kaa
final 50% of that money will be donated
will be contributed towards K's end in
making sure that or in doing their bit
in making sure that businesses are able
to thrive and survive uh these extremely
difficult and challenging time so 50% of
all premium sales go back to the
community so chess has done so much for
the community and now the chess
community Through chess can give back by
supporting uh by being a part of this
educational website for chess so you
also improve your own chess but also
give back to the community so definitely
consider doing that and as you can see
by the bar these have been the
contributions so far and uh we are uh we
are thankful for all of that Peter Peter
has contributed he's going through
buying premium memberships for talents
in Hungary uh all the money that's come
in for that 50% of that will be given to
Kaa and we also had one of our Legends
making a big contribution to this cause
a big big thank you to vasel ivanchuk uh
uh he's contributed $700 in premium
membership for players so he will be
gifting out these memberships and chess
2 24 will be giving 50% of that to Kaa
true chess just making making a big
impact and also we do have gam starting
up but before that a quick reminder to
all of you you can go premium and also
we have a great deal on on Anna's course
uh on attack how to attack how to attack
like a pro really Anna has amazing
experience and is a brilliant trainer
and you can this course is an absolute
must have definitely check out the
reviews and take a look at it for
yourself if you struggle with the
concept of how to build an attack and
how to execute it to Perfection how do
these top players combine all their
pieces and how does their attack always
seem to work while our tactics are
always flawed I highly recommend check
out this course by Anna and um uh play
like play like a really strong uh strong
how all these strong players attack and
basically yeah as Anna say she'll teach
you how to play like Alpha zero she's
also done some great videos on Alpha
Zero's games so Anna knows what she's
talking about definitely have a look
there's a 33% off and again 50% of that
will go into contributing towards K's
cause so there's really a lot going on
and I think we've got liftoff really
soon so let's see if Yas and Peter are
are back and they are so yes Peter
Daniel dubov in a must win situation to
take it to the to take it to tie breaks
today today's been a very very difficult
day for Daniel I have to say yes your
prediction on Hikaru is spot on so far
well thank you very
much T that was very very nice and again
as you say uh Danel is in a situation uh
where he must win and he must win with
the white pieces Peter winning on demand
toughest thing in chess yeah absolutely
but if we think about it exactly the
same situation was yesterday when
Danielle had to win the last game on
demand but his situation improved today
because he has the white pieces contrary
to to yesterday's uh situation and he
managed to buns back with the black
pieces so in this regard I feel like if
somebody can bounce back it's it's
Daniel and look at this E4 has been
played this is this is some of somewhat
of a surprise because
uh and Knight E4 E5 Knight C3 this
reminds me on the armagedon game between
the two of them which Daniel Duo won in
a very very quick manner against Hikaru
and won the final of the Lindor with it
you know it it was a striking example
because you know we kind of anticipated
that yeah Hikaru had the black pieces
he's very very fast and will Daniel have
chance or not and all of a sudden after
like 12 13 moves it was game over so
Daniel never give a chance for Hikaru to
show his real skills in Blitz well I
think a lot of players go through that
period in their life if they're E4
players and E4 E5 and they want to play
a Kings Gambit they really really do but
unfortunately F4 D5 has been so
off-putting for so many players that
committed King Gambit players oftentimes
use the Vienna move order of playing
Knight C3 in order to then play F4 then
after Knight C3 Knight F6 we didn't see
F4 we saw this move d4 and I believe
this is called the center
counter uh variation and queen D4 E3 is
the theoretical move and wouldn't you
not it at the moment I say queen D4 to
E3 theoretical move Danel comes out with
Queen D4 D3 likely also has been played
in the past but I'm more familiar with
Queen E3 uh what what do you know about
this Peter because to be honest I don't
know much yeah it's very interesting
because I even don't know if there is
any name of this because the one that
you you mentioned the the real Central
Gambit is E4 E5 D4 right and E D4 Queen
D4 Knight C6 Queen E3 that's how usually
you reach this position Knight F6 Knight
CC Bishop B4 Bishop D2 castles castles
this Castle is I mean I have to know
that I have to bling the king all the
way to h8 I'm I'm getting used to it but
sorry guys if I don't manage yeah now I
have to go all the way to A1 this is
because of the Fisher random the 960
that was the solution of the software so
that you can always Castle right uh so
long C rookie eight and there was a huge
debate in this variation and black is
doing perfectly fine according to to
Theory but E4 E5 Knight CC Knight F6 D4
spices things up because it's it's a
little bit different Queen takes D4
Knight C6 Queen D3 probably with the
inclusion of Knight F6 Knight C3 this
move Queen DC is
uh I I don't know how to put it it's
more I mean it's more possible or is
it's more sensible I I don't know
exactly if it's sensible at all but
that's why I don't know how to put it
but it makes uh it makes more sense
white developed the Knight and maybe he
has more uh more control of the center
and Hikaru went for Bishop
C5 okay and then Bishop F4 happened and
D6 long Castle I mean now if nothing
really happens white gets the chance to
play F3 then I would say that this is a
perfect scenario for white for a
must-win game for a must-win game
exactly especially if you see Kings on
opposite flanks uh exactly uh again
maybe this isn't the greatest opening uh
Innovation ever type of thing but
definitely in a must-win game uh you
have to you have to take risks
Peter yeah absolutely I mean and also
not just risk because what what does the
risk really mean in mod chess it's
already very difficult to Define but I
think the best definition is that you
want to get your opponent out of his
comfort zone as quickly as possible
because it's a quick time control if you
know that this line actually is quite
tricky it has it has a positional
background and uh maybe black has to be
very energetic to to punish you but I
mean black doesn't have the luxury to
spend so much time at the beginning so
he might rely on natural moves and after
a couple of natural moves then you get a
position which you are hoping for but
having said that Hikaru is not the
person to back down and he grabs the
pawn on B2 I mean on F2
sorry nice uh a man after my own heart
I'm a pong grubber having uh started uh
pong grubbers Anonymous I'm a proud card
carrying member
uh it does cost him some time Bishop it
cost him some time and and you know this
is I think one of Daniel's a part of
being very creative very strong and very
dangerous and quick and whatsoever but
he's he has an incredible poker face and
I think for this rapid chess games and
especially combined with his style
because he's taking he gambles he takes
a lot of risk and he you know that he is
like a Fanatic in preparation but you
never know that for example this
preparation
he plays it because he believes that
this is good or he just wants to put you
under pressure or he was hoping that you
are not taking this Pawn I mean there
are all these kind of questions but
after Bishop takes F2 he blitzes out
Knight F3 with the intention like of
course I knew that you're gonna take
this Pawn on F2 and I'm ready for it
right exactly and Bishop uh already
retreated I might have been a little bit
more anxious myself to get my king
castled but after Bishop B6 so I mean
the way I always thought in terms of
gambits and I loved gambits as I started
the game you know uh Paul morphe the
games of Paul morphe where he gets out
the pieces as quickly as possible um the
idea of a Gambit was you gave up
material to win time in terms of
development getting out your pieces
faster than your opponent so our
opponent has played Bishop C5 takes F2
and he's moved his Bishop back so he's
taken three moves to grab a pawn and
what we try to do is open up the game
because we're ahead uh on time and so a
move that you really really do want to
play as white here Peter is E4
E5 but you know unfortunately if we
forced to trade queens and play Bishop
takes E5 we have compensation but I
don't feel that's what we want to do
when we're gambiing uh so but I do feel
we want to play E5 so is it a a queen
move or is it
a what what would you recommend Danel do
right here he's already done it by the
way Bishop E2 yeah to be honest I didn't
know what I would recommend yeah because
clearly white wants to go E5 as Yer
mentioned
but in order to do that you have to put
your queen somewhere and there is no
real good Square something like Queen E2
with the idea of E4 E5 looks already too
premature because you block your own
bishop and black will probably play some
Queen E7 and we laugh into your face
that okay what what do you want from me
H so in this regard Bishop E2 does make
sense but on the other end it feels a
bit slow exactly exactly Bishop E2 uh
not exactly the effective Square for the
bishop uh I must say I'm not a fan and
like yourself I don't really have uh a
better solution I was really on the E5
Queen takes D5 Bishop takes E5 train and
I wasn't getting anywhere so okay let's
just go with Bishop E2 at least he's got
purpose Rook F1 Bishop G5 we could
imagine how uh White might see an
initiative Peter yeah black played the
move H6 it's the move I like very very
much because it's tempting to Castle
away but exactly short Castle would run
into Bishop G5 and this pin is really
really nasty you you can't really solve
it with H6 first of all Bishop H4 with
idea G5 Knight G5 looks very scary I
mean I say scary because it's enough to
know that this is possible and you just
stop looking at it another idea for
white is even some measures H6 H4 and
you just leave the bishop on G5 you are
setting to go Knight D5 using the pin
and whenever black takes on H5 H G5
opens the H file and it's again maybe
it's working maybe not but you even
don't want to find out so this looks
Taylor Made for Anis course by the way I
mean attacking like a machine I like the
H4 nice touch Peter yeah so after H6
Danielle said that he slowed done okay
you just understand that you you don't
have much so he played the move H3 it's
a it's a nice little move because one of
the things that black is also sing some
positional move Knight G4 yes you have a
direct idea with Knight F2 but also just
to get a very nice uh Square on E5 it's
the typical Square where you want to go
when white doesn't have a pawn to to
chase you away so in this regard H3 is
very nice and
it signals that I understand I'm P done
and but you still haven't castled and
after H I'm hinting the idea that if you
Castle yes I don't have Bishop G5 but I
have some G4 G5 coming and you might not
feel so comfortable and Hikaru says yes
I understand your idea I'm not intending
to Castle short let me just develop my
Bishop to E6 and if I will have time to
get my queen out and cast along I will
be very happy and Danielle immediately
goes Luke H1 saying aha I know your idea
you're not going to get away so easily
exactly because Bishop E6 is a trumpet
Clarion call that says yes Queen D7
Castle long and by the way that Bishop
on B6 will be a defensive monster
there's no way you're catching Black's
King if it gets Queens side now this
move Rook E1 on the other hand it
basically telegraphs I'm playing E4 E5
no matter what Peter or Knight D5 yeah
that's that's the other idea or or
Knight David five oh okay yes Knight D5
because that's also a way to to open up
the E
file and it's not that I was even
thinking that maybe Hikaru would uh I
don't know because you have the option
of taking with the bishop and then Ed
Goa Knight E7 that's why it was very
important to place the queen on D7
instead of E7 because then this E5 would
have been open but after Knight E7 I
still have some move like Queen B3 with
the idea of Bishop B5 which can be quite
annoying and if okay if you have the
luxury and time to play A6 everything is
fine but it's it's a time it's uh it's
it's something to to maybe work with I
don't know so I'm expecting something
like Knight D5 or if you can again put
this queen somewhere but this somewhere
is only B5 and A6 Maybe Queen A4 and try
to get this E4 E5 going somehow just as
you as you wanted I tell you Peter the
more I'm looking at it the less I
believe in the in the Gambit I want to
put it like that
um I think it's really the bishop on E2
that disturbs me the most it's just you
know it's like a
slug it's in the way you know if the
bishop was on B5 I think we would have
uh we would both be feeling that there's
more to it with the bishop on E2 I just
don't think that uh it's enough
compensation do we have Knight D5 by the
way is that yeah Knight D5 is on the
board okay I mean I think uh I think the
danger is that black should not
underestimate this uh this disposition
because if you just make one inaccuracy
and all of a sudden my pieces will make
sense you will be very angry at yourself
that you were not more careful yeah
right I uh I know that uh the Chinese
players the Chinese School of Chess they
love to play the Russian defense and I
gotta say they play it really well and
I've seen a lot of Chinese players in
these types of positions say go ahead
double my pawns let me Castle Queen side
anyway you mentioned Bishop takes D5 e
takes D5 Knight E7 is a possibility uh
what's your take about castles yeah I
mean long Castle was the other move I
wanted to show B but then I then I
wanted to pass it to you that you will
suggest long Castle I mean yeah long
Castle is a safe move and I would say
that if white would take on F6 being
Pawn done Knight takes F6 doesn't make
any sense because you have zero chance
of winning white has to keep the
pressure on I don't know exactly if
keeping the pressure on is Poss POS by
just taking this bishop but my idea is
not just taking but after A6 I would
love to go Queen A3 get some Queen A8
idea and if you react naturally with
King B8 then maybe I can somehow use
this E4 E5 idea yeah especially I wanted
to say the same thing in the center
counter that's why we so often see the
move Queen D4 to E3 so that we can use
the defile to play D E5 so I like what
you were just doing there Peter very
much for white playing Queen A3 with the
idea E5 then you can at least you're
exploiting The Rook on D1 uh in a very
nice way um so that was why I guess um
he car did he captured on D5 with his
Bishop yeah and it goes exactly along
the lines uh we discussed so Bishop D5 e
D5 Knight E7 because okay black is very
stable
but here I feel that these are the
typical positions where computer
actually might say that white has white
has maybe enough compensation you know
this is like the new way of thinking
this is the impact of the computers that
in all times we would say that okay we
are pwn up nothing is really happening
so what what is our problem slowly we
will win it but engines actually often
say that you know what you can take my
Pawn I have some activity and I can uh I
can work with that yeah this is this is
some new impact but I do feel that black
is way too solid to have any problems
and let's not forget about this E4
Square because I have something like
Knight G6 Bishop moves Knight E4 rook h8
in mind taking control of the squares
and just after I seeing it I see that
Daniel played Bishop C4 protecting D5
and getting control over the E4
Square uh Zach L and again I
I this bishop is not making a favorable
impression on my eyes okay yes you're
hitting the A6 Pawn yes you're defending
the D5 Pawn but for for for me
Black's moves are so easy You're Gonna
Play Knight G6 a move you mentioned it
comes with Tempo you're GNA play Rook on
h8 to E8 not just chopping off all the
Rooks but a Prelude to Knight E4 and you
got a pawn in the pocket I'm
thinking this ain't even close to
compensation it just
feels but black Black's play is a little
too easy uh Peter yeah Knight G6 played
and Bishop D2 this this feels to me like
Bishop D2 is a move you are in a
must-win situation and you are desperate
to create some idea and I don't if the
main idea is to go A4 A5 try to put the
pawn to to A5 then go Queen D3 and try
to sacrifice on A6 is that what Danielle
is in mind it I don't really believe
because it's just way too slow and
Hikaru has played Rook d8 very nice
little move because why to go Rook h8
when The Rook on d8 anyway does nothing
so he moves The Rook to E8 and wants to
maybe use the Rook along the H5 maybe he
anyway just wants to trade on E1 so ahuh
and the A4 idea had been used because
Rook d8
we had an
update white played Bishop D3 so it's
all about the E4 Square yeah Daniel
wants to make sure that black doesn't
get Knight E4 and now also there is a
threat of Bishop F5 winning the queen
thanks to the pin so of course Hikaru
immediately played King B8 and after
King B8 A4 had been played so white
comes now with the tempo King A8 A5 and
Bishop F2 blitzed out by
Hikaru right it seems like uh both
players have their agendas and I really
like what you were saying there I always
about the Rooks The Rook on d8 coming to
E8 I always try to stress whenever I'm
commentating how you want your pieces to
be effectively placed it's not just
enough to develop your pieces off the
bank rank you want them on effective
squares and you would say to yourself
The Rook on d8 wasn't particularly
effective not that The Rook 8 on h8 is
but there's more potential for The Rook
on h8 to become effective because of the
move that you indicated Peter H6 H5
could suddenly appear on black side of
the board and then the Rook on h8 is
actually perfectly placed so effective
play and after A5 with a Tempo well
Hikaru said I'm gonna return the tempo
I'm gonna play Bishop F2 yeah and also
one other point we should highlight with
Rook d8 that actually black made sure
that he has a nice little r Three Square
for the queen on d8 because just imagine
the white Pawn being on A4 let's just
play the same sequence with Rook h8 yeah
you go L straight Rook E8 Bishop D3 you
go King
B8 yeah yes I go A4 you go King A8 and I
go Bishop F5 clap your queen whoops
exactly so easy yeah to lose the game
and d8 prophylactic you make sure that
this uh threat never works
because as you say the d8 square is
vacated yes now you can just Retreat to
d8 and the bishop on F5 does nothing he
will have to retreat and okay thank you
very much so yeah and we have lot of lot
of action in the game wow I mean the
okay the players have to speed up yeah
it's it's correct because Daniel has to
feel that his chance is only if he can
put pressure on the clock yeah on on
Hikaru but Hikaru plays fast so it
forces is Daniel to also act
quickly yeah I mean uh trying to push
sharu
over uh over on the clock
well good luck with that a lot of
American Grand masers can tell you
that's not easy yaru is a blitz Legend
in American chess circles uh in
Hungary uh the Hungarian School of Chess
has got a lot of blitzers I know that uh
Judith loves to loves to Blitz I know
you're a very good Blitz player um why
is it that in Hungary uh Blitz is so and
it's been popular for all the time that
I play chess yes I think we will come
back to it but there is so much action
going look at this I mean basically it's
like yeah one thing is the must-win
situation for Daniel but on the other
hand it's also that Hikaru forces him to
take more and more risk because
otherwise if he's not going with the
flow he will have zero chances and he
will just be worce so now after H5 G5
Knight E4 we see this exchange sacrifice
with Knight E6 white has to go all in
and white can claim positional
compensation thanks to this powerful KN
the only problem is that black is
preparing to to sacrifice The Exchange
back with Rook E7 black wants to L h8
and then hit this Knight on E6 at the
right moment precisely that's that's the
point that a lot of amateur players
misunderstand about being material ahead
when you're material ahead it gives you
the freedom to return the material and
as Peter you're just saying you're G to
double up Rooks and you're prepared to
capture the Knight win the pawn by the
way black already is a pawn to the good
so Rook on h8 to E8 threatening taking
on E6 is uh
very promising I think the move Rook F3
is designed to play Rook to C3 uh Peter
yeah probably but to be honest there
were many many questions coming to my
mind I also did not really understand
what's wrong with Rook h8 continuing in
the in the same spirit with taking on E6
another move Queen B5 also came to mind
because with Rook on E7 actually you
protected the C7 Pawn
but Hikaru came up with a third option
C6 he just wants to to break this
structure first and also how to keep the
tension because you can't go C4 then I
can sacrifice immediately my rook and
you I just lost right and after C6
Knight f8 had been almost blitzed out
but wow Queen E8 Knight E6 does this
mean that white is already dreaming of a
repetition which Hikaru says with C
takes D5 play the tempo no thank you I'm
already completely winning I'm not gonna
let you go so easily yeah it's just uh
regardless of the outcome I think we can
definitively now say that whole Gambit
just didn't work whatsoever and uh White
is on the back foot Hikaru definitely in
big control in this game uh and it's a
deciding game a must-win situation uh
Danel has taken a lot of risk and they
haven't paid off we just see this move
Queen B6 Danel is hoping that he'll be
able to play something of the nature of
Rook C uh Rook F3 to uh C3 or B3 but
what queen d8 Peter first move comes to
my mind you probably have also some
other reputation ideas yeah actually my
main move was Queen e five but hear also
chooses an third one with Rook f8 yeah
okay but it just game over because the
Rook cannot really lift on the third
because then look F2 and you will give
the Checkmate first right this is this
is just over and you know while you were
telling something but Hikaru went Sona
and the Gambit and it didn't work out I
felt like exactly playing a Gambit style
against Hikaru is not the way to to to
to get success because Hikaru is just
way too good in all these things but uh
what to do if you are in a musine
situation yeah you feel kind of almost
obliged that you have to do something
crazy and Daniel has resigned Hikaru has
won the won the second set so he's
leading two Z wow uh powerful good Chess
By Hikaru Nakamura gives him a very
sizable uh advantage in uh his
semi-final match as he wins the American
wins the first two sets and has a a very
big lead whereas in our other
semi-finalist that semi-finalist between
dig Len and Magnus Carlson is currently
tied we hope that we will get Hikaru to
join us very shortly with Tanya so
please I warn you to get your questions
ready and send them to our hashtag
impact chess
hello
Tanya hi yes and we do have Hikaru with
us Hikaru congratulations on that second
set win thank
you today it was uh it looked like you
were in control from game one yesterday
was absolutely trading blows and up and
down but today was a lot more smooth
your impressions on the overall match
today yeah I mean I thought the match
really uh hint on sort of the the the
second game basically because um in in
the first game denil defended very well
I think I was supposed to be winning at
One Moment In this end game but I but I
missed it and then second game danil had
a very good position and he couldn't
convert um now I haven't looked at the
game so I don't know if there's a clean
win for white but I suspect somewhere
somewhere in this this queen and Rook
end game it should have been very very
good for him um yeah when he couldn't
convert this uh then game three I game
three was also a little bit unclear but
I I felt that the position was a little
bit too passive for danal we did have
Magnus on the show and he said that in
game three it looked like Daniel never
really equalized in the SW nikov did you
feel that you were better during the
game yeah I mean I I I I know this Rook
d8 move that he played was not the
correct move I think Rook fc8 was
supposed to be the correct move when I
looked very briefly um but yeah I I just
felt the position was a little bit too
passive and there wasn't enough uh there
wasn't enough sort of counterplay it
wasn't sort of position where you can be
creative and um and so I thought it was
just very um ve very very nice win and
that that of course once I won that game
the fourth game was kind of irrelevant
based on the
opening if you had to point out a
critical moment in game three where you
think black was substantially worse or
uh got into a lot of trouble where do
you think that happened I thought Bishop
F5 I don't know which move number that
was but there was a position where he
went Bishop F5 yeah like right here I
thought instead of Bishop F5 there had
to be something better like Bishop H4 or
Bishop G4 it felt like there should be
something here because when he went
Bishop
F5 um it just kind of it didn't didn't
sort of flow there the the move doesn't
really have a concept like if you want
to go Bishop G4 then you should just go
Bishop G4 right away and you also close
down the f file so all these Bishop H4
ideas like here Bishop H4 it attacks F2
but once you put the bishop on F5
there's no attack because you Clos the f
file um from your Rook so so yeah in
general I mean I I felt that yeah he
used a lot of time and then he couldn't
quite come up with the equalizing plan
and um and and then at the endend uh
there's just the B Pawn was too much
andar right about here when he when he
returned with Bishop E6 on the next move
and you instantly traded off this is I
was having a look with the engines and
it and it the advantage just really came
to you after this light squ Bishop
tradeoff can you uh did you feel that
during the game that this trade was uh
was that beneficial for you and why yeah
I mean I think one of the good things
about this position is that it's black
who has to find the Right Moves is not
so much on white because with white you
have one idea try to get the B Pawn to
B8 make a queen um or or else like black
is completely fine that's that's really
all it hinges on is the one pawn and
then the bishop and Knight versus the
two Bishops in the center so uh yeah I
had a feeling knight3 was good I I don't
know if I realized how good it was
because the other thing was denil was
laow on time so I thought just
practically speaking if we trade the
Bishops um the B6 Pawn is going to
become a monster and it's going to be
very very hard to
defend all right well it was uh it was a
very fascinating match and it looked
like you were at your dominating best
and Hikaru I have to ask you because I
noticed on Twitter that after the match
yesterday as well you know you you
stream on your Twitch Channel and of
course everything that you do for the
chess community and on Twitch is
absolutely phenomenal but these games
are so tough and the matches are so
tough so is that like a cool down for
you or how how does that how does it
work because you're playing in the
finals right now yeah I mean I guess the
the way I look at it is I've been doing
this for several months now where I've
been playing in these events and I've
been streaming afterwards so uh it
hasn't really affected me I've been able
to do preparation um there there are 24
hours in the day you know when all a
sudden done and um yeah I think for me
it's just it hasn't really impacted my
play and even if I'm a little bit tired
I think the analysis is is certainly a
lot easier than say playing Blitz games
like against Oli ruzer or somebody so uh
the the analysis itself isn't isn't that
isn't that tiring and I I enjoy it and I
think the fans do so it just seems to be
working
and do you also feel the support that
you get from your fans is also a big
motivating factor because this entire
tour you've gone into two finals uh one
quarterfinal it's it's been a very good
performance so far by you so do you
think that's a positive effect as well
to have all these supporters with you
yeah I think that certainly gives you
more motivation um obviously the prize
money is quite substantial but I think
when all of a sudden done at some point
it's more about the game there it isn't
solely about the prize money and so yeah
having all these fans supporting me uh
means a lot and I'm just trying to
trying to bring it home for
them all right that's uh that's really
nicely put Hikaru and uh yes spea any
any further questions for uh absolutely
uh for sure uh first of all hik car very
well done look like a very professional
performance so
congratulations no thank you yaser
absolutely uh second ofly it's kind of
at this tournament in particular our
hashtag is impact back chess uh how the
pandemic has impacted people's lives
it's impacted everybody's life obviously
but how did the pandemic affect you and
how did the how did chess uh play a role
and for you most especially we we're
going to be talking uh to lots of people
highlighting uh their lives and how the
pandemic played a role in their life and
how chess influenced them but for you
especially Hikaru uh the pandemic and
chess has caused you to be the world's
number one chess streamer how did that
come
about yeah I think I've been streaming
for quite a while even even prior to the
pandemic but certainly with the pandemic
going on and everyone everyone being
stuck at home uh I think everybody's
looking for an outlet and I don't think
it's solely solely my channel I there
are many chess channels that have been
doing very well during the pandemic um
you know I could talk about channels
like the chess br or Gotham chess um or
bz live there there many there are many
channels that are doing very well it's
not solely my channel so I think first
and foremost uh I should point that out
secondly um in terms of uh in terms of
becoming the top chess streamer it was
one of these things where I I I guess
it's kind of fitting but in in early
March like end of February early March I
took a vacation to Hawaii went to the
island of kawaii um and I was there for
two weeks and my mom actually came at
the end and I and I remember like
Looking Back Now towards the end markets
were crashing the pandemic was uh was
starting to become a very very big deal
because at that time my plan was after
the vacation to go into serious training
mode for the US championship and and
sort of at the end of that trip uh
everything started to started to fall
apart with the world and um it was
around that time that I just decided to
to stream uh fulltime because I'd gone
this vacation I was looking for
something to do and I just started
streaming every day and I'm very
thankful that there were so many fans
who were there watching even even before
it completely took off and it's just
been amazing I I really could never have
predicted that it would go in this path
but I think at the end of the day it's
been very beneficial for chess and chess
and for for the most part that that is
that is what matters the most and I'm
just very grateful there are so many
people online who love both my streams
but also the competitions that are going
on as well absolutely and thanks to your
efforts you brought in a whole new group
of people a whole new market I wanted to
say actually of people who would never
have discovered chess if in if you had
made it enjoyable uh for them and shared
so I just want to say thank you and I'll
turn it over to Peter who may have a
chess question or two for you let me add
one one thing quickly before we get off
topic the the one last thing that I
would add on that point um is that when
you look at the game of chess and I've
said this many times on my stream as
well I do very strongly feel that in
terms of being a game that is out there
and is known I think chess is by far and
way the most popular people know what
chess is so even if somebody doesn't
really know how to play the game of CH
everybody when they see the Kings the
Queens they see the piece they know what
the game is and I think the fact there's
so much uh so much exposure out there
there are a lot of people who played the
game when they were young they they
didn't play it Beyonce learning from
their parents or or playing in Middle
School in the chess club but but they
are coming back and they remember it and
because there's that that huge reach of
Chess I think that's what it is it's
more there a lot of people who played
for whatever period of time when they
were younger and now they're remembering
because they're they're getting on
Twitch or they're they're just watching
watching things on the Internet it's
like chess that game yeah I played it
many many years ago and and I think uh
at least I know my experience I think
for many people we do look back very
nostalgically on our childhood and I
think that is one of the biggest drivers
as well is that they're all these people
who have these very fond memories of
playing it as as kids and now they're
adults and and they're they're they're
remembering what a great game it is
recapturing their Glory of Youth well
again thank you and Peter H Jump Right
In you have a question or two perhaps uh
for uh
definitely I mean first of all
congratulations Hikaru it was a very
nice performance I was very happy to see
your handling of the sikov from the
white side I was already telling during
the broadcast of with yaser that brings
back the memories like 15 years ago when
I used to play with both colors and I
know that this positions are by far not
that simple for black and you I think
managed to prove it again in modern era
that yeah black has to be careful and
has to know his stuff very well another
thing and the question because with Yas
we had been truly impressed by your
defense here against Daniel in this in
the second game because as you mentioned
you have just missed the chance in the
first game to strike and then you had to
defend this very unpleasant position and
instead of falling apart you came up
with this H5 Queen G6 Queen G4 and all
this sequence it made a big impact
please tell us a little bit about this
defensive resource well first of all I I
spoke to Chris my second a little bit in
between the games and he said that
apparently H5 is losing that without H5
it's apparently supposed to be drawing
somehow but H5 is a losing move now I
don't know why this is supposed to be
losing because during the game I thought
that denil missed a golden opportunity I
thought if he had played H5 himself
instead of Rook C5 that he would have
had very good winning chances so during
the game I thought that after H5 would
be very very unpleasant um and I'm not
even sure if I would have been able to
draw the game but once he allowed me to
get H5 um all the ideas I thought become
very very straight forward here with
Queen G6 Queen G4 and I thought that was
really the critical point because once
he allowed H5 I mean I I think they're
supposed to be instead of Queen C2 if
you go back one move I think they're
supposed to be Queen D2 and queen A5 or
something which is winning um I don't
know why because I assume black can go
Rook A6 but apparently this is supposed
to be winning somehow for white I I
don't really know how but um but I but
during the game I felt that once I got
age5 it was just it was it was too hard
to prove and I I really thought from a
practical standpoint danil should have
played H5
himself yeah I mean we have been truly
impressed and we had also this
impression that you have to H5 yeah if
you are not computer then you are very
angry with white because you have a
clear aim with this queen G6 Queen G4
and the move Queen D2 did not even cross
our mind I mean that white puts the
queen on the dark squares in this
position this is something completely
unhuman yeah right agreed yeah I mean
and I I think maybe it's that one move
but it just felt like once I get Queen
G6 Queen G4 they're just there they're
you have to basically find some computer
maneuver some zwang where it's Black's
move in the wrong position to win and
and I just I I didn't see it during the
game so I was just I was very pleased I
drew this game because it felt like I
was in trouble for most of it yeah and
how did you
buy sense yeah that this beautiful idea
on the king side with H5 Queen to FC
combined with this tactical blow L BC
you should have been very proud of
yourself here no
yeah I was very happy because I thought
if I can get Rook D3 I should be drawing
but I I don't know if I was actually
precise here at the end because it's
queen queen and pawn end game I don't
think was as drawn as I thought it was
but but anyway with the activity of the
queen and the Rook uh it was there was
never really going to be any danger at
this point yeah in any case it had a
huge impact on us because we felt like
wow I mean uh we I mean when somebody
has a better position in a rapid game
it's so easy to play but defending
difficult positions I think also one of
the most important qualities of the top
players and I mean here you have truly
masterfully defended driving Daniel
crazy and then striking in the third
game well very well played
congratulations I have nothing to add
back to Yas and
Tanya well thank you for that Peter and
yeah iaro is kind of hilarious because
you were explaining why you felt he had
to play H5 and you were also explaining
how how glad you were to play H5 then
when you talk to Chris he says oh yeah
your H5 is losing and you're like what
yeah I mean that's that's just I mean I
think that's just computer chust that's
just computer chust the other day and in
a rapid game I think one of the things
that's most important is to try and play
things that are logical as opposed to
trying to find the best moves like for
example the chesnov I suspect is very
draw with correct play and in a
classical game I think denil probably
draws this plus but in a rapid or a
Blitz game when the time starts getting
lower and there aren't obvious moves
it's a little bit hard just sit around
and play sort of random moves and so I I
think it was it was a very smart
decision by me to play this and um and
it worked out so I'm pretty happy it
certainly did work out and I'd like to
just before I let you go just one more
quick question and I like to bring Tanya
into this especially because um Hikaru
Tanya was interviewing Magnus and Magnus
had some very interesting thoughts that
he'd like to share regarding the World
Championship uh format the format for a
world championship match uh and I'd love
for you to join in this discussion as
well because essentially Tanya asked him
about the classical chess and he and and
Magnus essentially said that classical
chess is really really tough and he
really likes formats that include what
you're seeing here in the Magnus Carlson
tour of Blitz and rapid so Tanya um
recall to try to be accurate here with
what Magnus really was suggesting for
world championship match format so hiar
that was about the world championship
format and including classical rapid and
Blitz to decide the world champion
rather than basing classical world
champion rather than having a classical
world champion purely on classical games
and I think this is something that we
had spoken about as well at the Tata
Steel in Kolkata and you were of the op
opinion that uh to decide the world's
best player he needs to be strong in all
formats and this was a conversation that
we had because earlier in the Legends
Anatoli as well as Gary believed that a
classical world champion should be
decided on classical games what's your
take on this yeah I mean it's very very
hard it it depends what you're trying to
balance you have to balance between
sponsors because we we need sponsors for
the game of chess and what is say Pure
Chess per se um so for example in the
old days as we know from the famous
kaspar of carbo matches I think they
played to what was it his first like
seven wins or something I think they
played this insane 48 yeah whatever it
was they played this insane six wins
yeah they played this insane match that
went like 50 games and took like 10
million years um so so yeah on the one
hand I do agree with that I think really
the issue is sort of the way chess
preparation has become now um you're
seeing a lot of draws and the fact that
you the world championship end with 12
draws and then Magnus win in Rapid chess
I think that sort of says a lot about
the state of classical chess when
players have a lot of time to prepare
and when they can find the absolute
perfect move so so to me I I think
classical chess still should exist but I
would make the argument that um that
perhaps the time format should be
shortened is is what I would recommend
is instead of having these games that go
seven hours you change it to something
like I don't know you have like uh you
have like hour 30 or a little bit less
and then you have one hour for the rest
of the game so it's sort of a hybrid
between the two um because otherwise I
think with the way preparation is gone
and players getting like move 20 uh
before they have to think when you have
two hours to make 20 moves the the
Perfection the amount of uh the the
quality of the moves is just going to be
far too high and people are not going to
um make
mistakes how do you feel about it
perhaps and this is what the what the
Tweet had at that moment of having a set
set like we have here kind of a play
where you have let's say a set with a
certain number of matches and in case
it's a in case a match ends in a tie
every day it goes into uh it goes into a
tie break uh how do you feel about that
about having yeah I mean
yeah but I mean the problem the problem
again is what happens when you have when
you play like you play two games because
I assume you're saying traditional
classical or something even shorter with
two games what happens when the two
games are drawn you have the same
problem you have the problem of the draw
and and so then if you have it drawn but
then you have rapid games I mean it it's
kind of I I don't know it doesn't it
doesn't feel feel right so so I I'm of
the of the opinion that in general
something has to change I don't quite
know what it is I still like the idea of
classical chess deciding the world
champion but if every game is going to
end in a draw I don't really know um I I
don't know what the solution is right
thanks for inside and I do remember
hiari that you mentioned even when Fabby
was going to play in the world
championship match that it is very
important to be strong in all formats in
today's time with blitz and Rapid
becoming a prominent feature in the
Chess World uh so uh congratulations for
today and we look forward to your games
tomorrow great I'll see you guys
tomorrow thank you hararo yeah thank you
good luck bye bye
and Tanya uh not quite the fireworks and
explosive decisive games uh from the
first day but nonetheless a very
enjoyable uh day two of the semi finals
I think yes all these guys need to take
a look at Anna's course on how to attack
like a machine no the jokes apart you
absolutely right a very very different
um brand of Chess today as you put it
yourself uh yesterday was all about
aggressive play and blows and counter
blows and uh while today what we saw was
positional masterpieces and positional
uh
resources I think I think very very
exciting chess as well but a different a
different brand of Chess altogether and
Hikaru Nakamura takes a two- match lead
in his best of five which basically
means that potentially this match if
Hikaru takes it tomorrow as well he
qualifies for the finals So Daniel dubar
has to win at least two more matches
right now to equalize the score and
Magnus Carlson bounced back from his
defeat his match defeat yesterday
wrapping up today's match in three games
in absolutely dominant Magnus style and
I have to say yes Peter that it looked
like today ding never really got a
chance to come into the game your final
thoughts about the play that we had
today uh Peter go for it yeah somehow I
don't know it it felt like I mean ding
made a wrong choice in the very first
game of of today because first of all he
yesterday he pulled up a miracle he beat
Magnus in the blitz playoff and I think
he must have been really relieved and
with this Victory yesterday he had kind
of the initiative in the match but but
his uh choice in the opening and we can
just go there very quickly I mean he
chose a line first of all where he has
no experience secondly this end game is
slightly worse and to make things worse
you do this against Magnus Carson who is
the best in the world dealing with this
situation so I somehow felt like uh okay
if ding would have drawn this first game
then one could have said wow great
strategy and maybe it would have worked
out perfectly for this but the way the
game went that he lost it then it it
felt like the whole strategy did not
make any sense Magnus got back to his
comfort zone like okay he's leading he
doesn't have to do anything crazy with
black uh he went back to his usual E4 E5
where he feels very very comfortable and
played a truly Masterpiece in the in the
second game where maybe uh knowing the
the situation that Ding lost the first
game he was also encouraging Magnus to
to to take risk but Magnus was saying
okay please if I'm given a chance to
sacrifice the pawn for initiative I will
do it and after that incredible win by
Magnus the match was practically over so
ding never really got a chance to get
into the game Magnus just crushed today
but I would say that it doesn't really
mean anything for the match it just
means that now both players are kind of
satisfied because okay ding is anyway
happy that he is fully the match Magnus
is back and I'm expecting a brutal Third
Day between them thank you Peter uh best
out of three
anyone very nice uh match indeed and I
just wanted to say once again to
everybody in audience thank you so much
for joining us and sharing your day uh
tell everybody where you're hanging out
and thank you everyone for all your
support for Kea and what we're trying to
do in these finals you saw the the bar
there and I I every time I look I'm very
happy to say that it keeps going up so
thank you for to everybody who's
donation who's donating and you can also
support by becoming a member of Chess 24
and or uh doing yourself a real service
by buying uh Anna Rudolph's uh chess
course and
Tanya we're going to do it all again
tomorrow I cannot wait yes because it
means it's a must-win situation for
Daniel dubov going into the third set
and of course the ding Magnus match is
wide open but I have to say that if
Magnus takes a lead in that match it is
going to be difficult for ding to bounce
back at least I'm glad that Ding is not
facing the internet issues that he has
in the past and he can at least just
just put out his best chess I'm hoping
for more day one ding than day to ding
in that matchup and absolutely right
that we have an we have an incredible
deal on Anna rudol course International
Master Anna who with her experience is
going to teach us how to attack like a
machine it's a 33% off and um uh 50% of
the proceeds from this course also go to
K's cause we're going to be talking a
little more about that but before before
we go on to that let's take a look at
what we heard on Twitter from our
audience yes we had Grandmaster David
writing in with must admit I've got a
small man crush on both yasa and Peta
two super strong players and equally
great
commentators Yas would you like to
respond to
David uh David well first of all I got a
really good chance uh when David visited
St Lewis he's he's a sweetheart I can't
believe he's such
a a great attacking Grandmaster because
when you really get a chance to talk to
him he's uh just a fun loving guy so a
big shout out to David hello I hope the
uh pandemic is treating you and your
family well uh David thank you so much
for joining and you know all compliments
gratefully received thank you shout out
to David uh he himself has uh been
commentating and been a fantastic
commentator at jalta last year uh so
happy that you're following the event
and enjoying it all right let's take a
look at the next one yeah just a second
let me add something as well to it I
mean it's such a pleasure to be
commentating with Y because I have seen
all his broadcast during all these grest
tours and US championship and so on and
you know it felt like it will be so nice
to team up and now in these finals we
got the chance I'm very happy and it
makes Incredible pleasure just to be and
commentating with with Y I'm I'm very
happy about it me too Peter I back you
up 100% on that uh uh you're you're
you're my duge you're my roof you you
you protect
me yes Peter you guys make an incredible
team and that's what we've been hearing
about on our social media as well on the
chat everybody is really enjoying your
insights Peter as well as your expertise
on chess and just how much you know um
every time there's anything that comes
up in a game that was played five years
ago you remember it and you bring that
up and it's incredible to see that and
yes you are uh no words can can justify
just what an amazing commentator you are
let's go on to your next tweet before
this becomes a yes Peter appreciation
broadcast exactly just a second I I'm
tearing
up okay okay okay I think I'm ready for
the next one Tanya all right we had
Anish writing in with might do a late
evening chill stream to catch up on all
the MC tour finals action of yesterday
and today hash impact chess # grow the
game Anisha has of course taken the
YouTube World by stor with his stream so
definitely check them out and uh some
great content there and of course this
is um as he says uh grow the game and
this is what you were talking to Hikaru
about as well and that has been exactly
what chess 24 has also done by putting
this entire Magnus Carlson chest tore
together uh in a very very difficult
time and it's all come down to where we
are right now the Magnus Carlson chest
benefiting Kaa finals and again do
consider going premium because this is
really an amazing opportunity for the
chess Community for all of us who have
enjoyed the tour who watched all of it
been a part of it to not only to not
only improve our game through the
educational uh resources that are
available on chess 24 to not only
interact with the best in the world uh
on banter blits and with q&as to not
only challenge them there and uh and all
of that all the benefits that come with
being a premium member but also doing
your bit to give back in a very
difficult time uh to businesses that
have been impacted by uh by the pandemic
as uh as Hikaru was himself saying that
you know it's h it's something that's
that's impacted and that's had an effect
on all of us and if there's anything
that we can do it's um it's to help the
community and what better way to do that
than through learning about Chess so no
better time and once again a big shout
out to Anna Rudolph's course on
attacking like machine uh it's it's a
brilliant course and definitely get your
hands on it if you want to learn how to
how to improve your tactics and how to
let let the attack flow in your position
because I know a lot of us struggle with
that you know we see we see these top
guys do it with ease but it's never easy
in our own games so uh a very
instructive course by International
Master Anna Rudolph check that out and
uh yes with that it's a wrap for today
and of course yes this we just a just
another information that we have this
amazing bar which talks about all the
all the contribution that has come in
for for Kaa by the chess community and
we've seen this bar go up and we also
receiv received uh let's have that
screen back up again we also received a
contribution by David by David Martinez
thank you David so much you've seen him
on our Spanish broadcast and he has
given he's contributed 15 almost 60 EUR
in premium membership supporting Kaa 50%
goes to Ka
and by donating these memberships so
that's the other way that you can do it
if you're already a member a premium
member consider buying or donating these
memberships to perhaps your students or
perhaps a school or your friends just
whoever is interested in chess uh
because like Yas was speaking to Hikaru
that chess has been has just boomed
during this pandemic and it's this
feeling of nostalgia of being able to
play the game and there's a desire to
improve on it and no better better time
than to do do that right now and that
bar that you see often on the broadcast
tells us how far we've come in our
Endeavor to support chest to support
everything that chess 24 does and to
support our communities and on that note
I'm going to call it a night and uh we
will see you tomorrow thank you thank
you Tanya thank you everybody good night
yeah thank you Tanya thank you y yeah
bye bye
[Music]
everyone
oh
[Music]
h